THEIR TODAY'S HEARING IS-
CERTAINLY- HERE LIVE IN PERSON
WE ALSO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY LATER ON
THE HEARING THE ACCESS PUBLIC
COMMON NUMBERS ON THE AGENDA AND
I'LL REPEAT THAT LATER IN THE
HEARING- SO TODAY OF COURSE IS
FOCUSING ON PRIMARILY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. ARE
ARE- TODAY. IN IN CALIFORNIA
HERE- YOU KNOW CERTAINLY PROUD
OF CALIFORNIA AS FAR AS-
ECONOMIC BASE BUT ALSO UPWARD
MOBILITY. AND- FOUND WE HAD A
BIG DEBATE YESTERDAY ON
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA BERKELEY
EMISSIONS AND DECISION ON THE
COURT CASE AND SEE WHAT UPDATES
AND SO THIS GETS TO THE CRUX OF
THE ISSUE IS ACCESS TO THE
COVETED- UC SYSTEM AND THAT'S
ALWAYS A CERTAINLY A TOP TOP
PRIORITY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS OVERALL
PROVIDING ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR
THE UNIVERSITY TO CONTINUE WITH
THEIR MISSION. SO WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR TODAY ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FOR YOU SEE
. AND HASTINGS HERE AN UPDATE
FROM THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
ON THEIR BUDGET AND AGAIN FOCUS
ON OUR TOP PRIORITY ENROLLMENT.
A LAST YEAR'S BUDGET PROVIDED A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN FUNDING
FOR THE UC- YOU KNOW SOME-
BOOSTERS AND HIGHER AND YOU SEEN
OTHERS CALL THE YOU KNOW THE
BEST BUDGET EVER. FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY COMING AFTER COATED
WITH THAT YEARS OF CUTS AND
PREDICTABILITY AS FAR AS WE WERE
HEADED- BUT WE DID HAVE. A
RECORD AMOUNT OF MONIES IN THE
BASE FUNDING IN ONE TIME MONEY
TO SUPPORT THE UC PLUS. MASSIVE
ENROLLMENT INVESTMENT WHICH WILL
GET TO. THAT'S WHY THIS IS GOING
TO TALK ABOUT HERE IS A BIT OF
DISAPPOINTMENT LEGISLATURE THAT.
THAT YOU SEE IS NOT- ABLE TO
FOLLOW THROUGH SO FAR ON THE
AGREEMENT WE MADE LAST YEAR. TO
INCREASE ENROLLMENT BY SEVEN
THOUSAND ROUGHLY NEW STUDENTS AT
WINNER STAND THAT YOU SEE OVER
AND ROLLED- STUDENTS- TWO YEARS
AGO AND IT TOOK ROUGHLY TWO
YEARS TO COUNT HOW MANY THEY
ACTUALLY HAD THAT'S GREAT NEWS.
WE'RE HAPPY ABOUT THAT AND I CAN
WE TALK ABOUT IT LATER BUT WE DO
SUPPORT FULLY FUNDING. EVER
STUDENT SHOWS UP BUT YOU SEE
LIKE WE DO AT OUR K. TWELVE
SYSTEM I THINK THERE IS THIS.
PROBLEM WE'VE HAD AFTER THE
RECESSION WE'RE- YOU KNOW IN K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS YOU KNOW YOU YOU
YOU FIND HIS THEIR WHO SHOWS UP
AND THEN YOU SEE WE HAVEN'T
ALWAYS. HAD IT LIKE THAT FOR UC
AND CSU SO I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
FIXING THAT ISSUE. SO WE CAN
HAVE A TRUE UP AFTER THE YEAR TO
MAKE SURE WE FIND ACTUAL.
ENROLLMENT AT THE UC. BUT AGAIN
IT IS- DISAPPOINTING THAT- THE
SPEAKER THE PRO TAB OF THE
BUDGET SHARE. AND THE SENATE
ASSEMBLY WE ALL HIGHLIGHTED THE
SEVEN THOUSAND NEW STUDENTS ARE
GONNA START THIS FALL. AND NOW
THAT IS IN QUESTION SO WE WANT
TO GET TO THE CRUX. AT AND
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD- WE DID FIND THOSE-
SLOTS IN THIS IN THIS BUDGET SO
THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE WE HAVE TO
SORT OUT- AGAIN ACCESS TO THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS AS A TOP TOP
PRIORITY AND- WE HOPE TO- FIND
AT. A PATH THAT WE CAN ALL. BE
PROUD OF HERE TODAY- SO WITH
THAT. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH-
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. AND
ISSUE NUMBER ONE ENROLLMENT. WE
HAVE A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
ALEJO. AND THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA IN THAT ORDER THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING- JAX WEALTH
BERMAN OF FINANCE- THE COMPACT
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- SETS CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS REGARDING
ENROLLMENT GROWTH. IN THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO SUPPORTING
THAT GROWTH. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES NINETY EIGHT
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT INCREASED CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT MOMENT BY BOTH
INCREASING. CAPACITY AND BY
FUNDING THE FIRST YEAR MULTI A
PLAN TO REPLACE NONRESIDENT
STUDENTS- WITH RESIDENTS
STUDENTS AT THREE CAMPUSES- IN
ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PLAN WOULD GROW RESIDENT MOMENT
BY ABOUT 1% ANNUALLY BEGINNING
AND- TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE- EVERYONE MORE THAN EIGHT
THOUSAND MORE CALIFORNIANS BY
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. TWENTY SEVEN.
AND INCREASING GRADUATE STUDENT
ROLE THAT BY TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DURING THE SAME PERIOD THANKS.
IF YOU CAN GO. YOUR FROZEN.
PLEASE LET TO MIMIC SOME. OKAY
THANK YOU SORRY ABOUT THAT SOME
CONFUSION THERE- L. A. L. DUSAN
CONCENTRA ROSELLI- IF YOU WANT
HAS TO TOPICS IN IT THE FIRST
RELATES TO ENROLLMENT DECISIONS-
THAT WERE MADE IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AFFECTING ENROLLMENT IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
SEVEN THE SECOND TOPIC IS AROUND
INVOLVEMENT IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED FUTURE
YEARS SOLVED QUICKLY TOUCH ON
EACH TOPIC. ALL ON THE FIRST
TOPIC I THINK TERM MCCARTY USED
COMMENTS- SUMMARIZE THE ISSUE
QUITE WELL BUT TO FURTHER
ILLUSTRATE THE SITUATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE YOU COULD TURN TO
PAGE FOUR OF YOUR AGENDA. THERE
IS A SURE TABLE ON KATE I'M
SORRY PAGE FIVE OF HER GENDER
THERE'S A SHORT TABLE ON PAGE
FIVE OF YOUR AGENDA. FIRST ROW
THE MOMENT EXPECTATIONS UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND GET
THE GOVERNOR BUDGET IS INTENDING
TO IMPLEMENT DECISIONS ARE MADE
OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET SO THAT
200-700-0200 SEVEN HUNDRED
RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATE. STUDENTS
WILL REFLECT GROWTH OF SEVEN
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO STUDENTS OVER THE LEVEL AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SECOND
ROW SHOWS UC'S PLANS AND IT'S A
BIT LOWER IT SHOWS ENROLLMENT OF
JUST OVER TWO HUNDRED ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. THAT'S
ABOUT FOURTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS
MORE THAN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IF HE'S PLANNING TO SPEND
THE REMAINING FUNDS ON OVER
TARGETED ROMAN IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SO THE QUESTION FOR
LEGISLATORS HOW TO RESPOND TO
THESE ISSUES AND- WITH A FEW
RECOMMENDATIONS HERE. ONE IS TO
TREAT UC'S PLANTED ROMAN LEVEL
AS THOSE SORT OF BASELINE LEVEL
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. THE REASON FOR THIS IS
BECAUSE YOU SEE IT IS CURRENTLY
MAKING FALL ADMISSION DECISIONS
BY THE TIME THE BUDGET IS
ENACTED IT WILL HELP ONCE WE
FINALIZE THOSE POLITICIAN
DECISIONS. I'M ALSO LOOKING
LIKELY WILL BE SORT OF THE
BASELINE THAT UC'S WORKING OFF
OF FOR RESIDENT. MOMENTS IF YOU
WERE TO TREAT THAT THEY- AS A AS
THE BASIS FOR FUNDING THAT
FOURTEEN HUNDRED STUDENT GROWTH
ESTIMATE WOULD COME TO ABOUT
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
YOUR AGENDA STARTS EARLIER
ESTIMATE WE PROVIDED IN OUR
REGIONAL ANALYSIS OF FORTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS WORKING
OFF SOME. PRELIMINARY DATA THAT
YOU SEE PROVIDED THIS THIRTY
SEVEN MILLION REFLECTS THE
UPDATED INFORMATION. ON THE- NOW
THE LEGISLATURE COULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ABOVE- THAT
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION UP TO THE
ENTIRE NINETY NINE MILLION
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR- DOING
SO WOULD EFFECTIVELY PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THAT OVER TARGET
GROWTH AND TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THE OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
RECENT YEARS HASN'T PROVIDED
FUNDING FOR OVER TARGET GROWTH.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE WAS A
UNIQUE SITUATION- THAT WAS A
PERIOD OF WHEN THERE IS A
PANDEMIC THERE IS A PARTICULARLY
LARGE GROWTH AND DEMANDS TO
INVOLVE DURING THE SUMMER. THE
UNIQUE SITUATION THE LEGISLATURE
COULD MAKE CONSIDER MAKING IT A
SUFFIX OPTION FOR THIS YEAR. AND
THEN THE SECOND TOPIC AND ROMAN
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR- THREE HUNDRED NOTES THE
LEGISLATURE RECENT YEARS HAVE
BEEN SETTING TARGETS FOR BUDGET
YOUR PLUS ONE. THAT APPROACH IS
INTENDED TO BETTER SIGNAL
LEGISLATIVE EXPECTATIONS FOR.
THE UPCOMING YEAR GIVEN THAT
POLITICIAN DECISIONS ARE USUALLY
MADE UP BEFORE THE BUDGET IS
ENACTED IN JUNE. I WOULD
RECOMMEND- TAKING THIS APPROACH-
ONE OF PRACTICE WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER DOING
IS SETTING UP- A- LEVEL TARGET
RATHER THAN GROWTH TARGET STONE
SERVE SPECIFYING GROWTH OF SAY
FIVE HUNDRED OR A THOUSAND OVER
HOW MANYHOW MUCH GROWTH THE
LEGISLATURE INTENDS. IT ACTUALLY
I SENT THE BUDGET THE SPECIFIC
LEVEL SO IT MIGHT BE TWO HUNDRED
TWO THOUSAND OR TWO HUNDRED
THREE THOUSAND RIGHT WHATEVER
THE LEVEL THE LEGISLATURE
INTENDS. BIGELOW TARGET WITH
BETTER. LEGISLATIVE EXPECTING
AROUND. AND HELP AVOID SOME OF
THE SITUATION LEGISLATURE SPACE
IN THIS YEAR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE NOW HEAR FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY AND
SAY OVER TEN AND REPRESENTING
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HOPEFULLY MY AUDIO IS COMING
THROUGH WELL IT WAS FREEZING
EARLIER SO- THANK YOU. SHOULD DO
IF YOU CAN HEAR ME- THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
THANKFUL THE GOVERNOR YOU SOME
FOR THE SUBSTANTIAL BUDGET
INTRODUCTION AND WE ARE
REQUESTING THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE PROPOSED NEW
FUNDING FOR THE UNIVERSITY.
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA IS
COMMITTED TO GROWING ACCESS FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WE RECOGNIZE
THAT ECONOMIC SECURITY AND
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY ARE
CONNECTED AT THAT ACCESS TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WILL
GIVE OUR FUTURE STUDENTS THE
CHANCE TO PURSUE THEIR DREAMS.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY ENROLLS NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES AN INCREASE OF
OVER TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED F. TO YOU FROM A DECADE
AGO. AND AN INCREASE OF OVER
NINE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AT
TWENTY THIRTY THERE USED TO BE
JUST SOME PRESIDENT DRAKE ONE TO
INCREASE THE UNIVERSITY'S
ENROLLMENT BY TWENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS. INCLUDED AND THIS
PROPOSED GROWTH ARE SIXTEEN
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES AND FOUR THOUSAND
GRADUATE STUDENTS. UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS INCLUDE THE REPLACEMENT
OF FOUR THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
NONRESIDENT STUDENTS WITH
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES SIXTY
SEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
ONGOING FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATE
INVOLVEMENT. BY SIX THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY STUDENTS BY
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
THE UNIVERSITY APPRECIATES THIS
PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN OUR
STUDENTS AND WE REQUEST YOU
SUPPORT THESE FUNDS. WE DO HAVE
A REQUEST ON HOW THE PROPOSED
ENROLLMENT GROWTH OF SIX
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
STUDENTS WOULD BE MEASURED. THE
LAST TIME THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED THE UNIVERSITY WITH
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FUNDS WAS IN
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AT THAT TIME YOU FUNDED
FOUR THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
SIXTY STUDENTS. OVER TWO YEARS
AT OUR CAMPUSES. WE ARE GRATEFUL
TO YOU FOR YOUR INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND THE
MULTI YEAR FUNDING YOU PROVIDED
THAT ALLOWED THE CAMPUS IS TO
HIRE INSTRUCTORS. IN A TIMELY
WAY. UNIVERSITY THIS TARGET UP
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY
STUDENTS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ACADEMIC CYCLE. WE
ARE REQUESTING THAT YOU FUND ALL
THE STUDENTS ABOVE THE FUNDED
ENROLLMENT TARGET SET IN THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN
WITH THE BOOK MARGINAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION. ONE POSSIBLE WAY TO
DO THIS IS TO COUNT THIS PRIOR
YEAR ENROLLMENT TOWARDS THE GOAL
OF SIX THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY NEW STUDENTS. THE
UNIVERSITY WANTS TO PROVIDE ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS WITH EQUAL
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE AND
FUNDING THE STUDENTS WILL ALLOW
US TO HIRE THE FACULTY TO TEACH
THE COURSES. AND THE STAFF TO
PROVIDE THE ACADEMIC SERVICES
THAT THE STUDENTS. SERVICE THE
GREAT RECESSION THE UNIVERSITY
HAS SEEN A STEADY EROSION AND
THE STUDENT TO FACULTY RATIO OF
STUDENTS SATISFACTION WITH THE
UC EDUCATION. WELL THE 200063%
OF UNDERGRADUATES REPORTED NOT.
GET THE MAJOR OF. THIS IN TWENTY
TWENTY THIS NUMBER HAD GROWN
211% OF UNDERGRADUATES. THIS
EROSION OF QUALITY AND ITS
IMPACT ON RETENTION RATE TO
STUDENTS IS LARGELY DUE TO OVER
TARGET ENROLLMENT OF STUDENTS.
AND THE DECREASING DOLLARS PER
STUDENT RECEIVED BY THE CAMPUS
SINCE. YOUR KIDS ARE ROLLED
ABOVE THE TARGET ENROLLMENT SAID
IN THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. WOULD MEAN THAT WITH
THE FUNDS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE CAMPUS IS
COULDN'T ROLL AN ADDITIONAL
TWELVE HUNDRED NEW CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. HOWEVER THE
UNIVERSITY IS AWARE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO DO UNIVERSITY EVEN
FURTHER. WITH THAT ADDITIONAL
FIVE POINT THREE MILLION ON TOP
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
UNIVERSITY COULDN'T ROLL AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS. FOR A TOTAL OF ONE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED NEW
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES IN THE
FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. IN
ADDITION TO THIS ENROLLMENT
GROWTH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES THIRTY ONE MILLION ON
GOING FOR THE UNIVERSITY TO
REPLACE. NINE HUNDRED AND TO
NONRESIDENT UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS WITH CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT STUDENTS. FOR PAUL
TWENTY TEN THROUGH- THE UC
BERKELEY UCLA AND UC SAN DIEGO
CAMPUS AS- THE CAMPUSES ARE
PREPARING TO PROVIDE ADMISSIONS
OFFERS FOR FALL TWENTY TWENTY
TWO INVOLVEMENT. AND ALL THREE
CAMPUSES INTEND TO REPLACE THREE
HUNDRED NONRESIDENT STUDENTS.
WITH CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES
TO REACH THIS NINE HUNDRED AND
TWO STUDENT REPLACEMENT GOAL.
RECEIVING THE FUNDING FOR THE
NON RESIDENT REPLACEMENT IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE CAMPUSES RELY
ON THESE FUNDS FOR MANY ASPECTS
OF THE CAMPUS OPERATIONS FROM
HIRING FACULTY TO TEACH MORE
COURSES TO STUDENTS SERVICES TO
MAINTAINING THE CAMPUS
FACILITIES. CURRENTLY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED OVER 12% OF CAMPUS CORE
FUNDS FROM NONRESIDENT
SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION PAID BY NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS. THEN THERE
WERE THE ROLE MY GROWTH AND NON
RESIDENT REPLACEMENT PLAN MEANS
THAT WITH THE CURRENT FUNDING
PROVIDED AND IN ADDITIONAL FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION I MENTIONED
EARLIER. UC CAMPUSES COULD ADD
UP TO TWO THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES WE'RE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE. FOR
FALL TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
UNIVERSITY RECEIVED THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF UNDERGRADUATE
APPLICATIONS IN OUR HISTORY AND
ADMITTED OUR MOST DIVERSE
FRESHMAN CLASS EVER. THE
UNIVERSITY ALSO ENROLLED MORE
LACK NEXT STUDENTS IN FALL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAN EVER
BEFORE AND MORE AFRICAN AMERICAN
GRADUATE STUDENTS THAN IN ANY
PREVIOUS YEAR. TO CONTINUE ON
THE SUCCESS THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES TO SUPPORT THE
UNIVERSITY IN FUTURE YEARS WHAT
1% ANNUAL ENROLLMENT GROWTH THIS
ENROLLMENT GROWTH WOULD BE
FUNDED THROUGH THE 5% ANNUAL
BASE BUDGET INCREASES WE WILL
DISCUSS IN THE NEXT ITEM.
SUPPORT FOR THIS AT DIGITAL
INVOLVEMENT IS VITAL TO
PROVIDING INCREASED ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY TO FOR FUTURE UC
STUDENTS. THE 1% GROWTH WOULD
TRANSLATE TO ROUGHLY TWO
THOUSAND NEW CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES ANNUALLY. ENDED
ANNUAL STATE SUPPORT COST OF
ROUGHLY TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY
FIVE MILLION AS ENROLLMENT
GROWS. IN ADDITION THE
GOVERNOR'S MULTI YEAR BUDGET
PROPOSAL INCLUDES ENROLLMENT OF
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED NEW
GRADUATE STUDENTS BETWEEN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND TWENTY FOUR
AND TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN WITH
THE FUNDING COMING FROM THE
PROPOSED 5% BASED BUDGET
INCREASE. SOME OF THE PROPOSED
NEW INVOLVEMENT WILL BE
ACCOMMODATED THROUGH INCREASED
ONLINE LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES BY
INCREASING GRADUATION RATES TO
ALLOW FOR THEIR THROUGHPUT OF
STUDENT. AND INCREASED
UTILIZATION OF SUMMER SESSIONS.
IN CLOSING WE REQUEST THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE FUNDING FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR YOU SEE
INVOLVEMENT BUT CHANGE THE
MEASUREMENT FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH TO BE FROM THE FUNDED
LEVEL OF THE BUDGET ACT OF.
TWENTY NINETEEN THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU I'LL HAVE A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS BUT TURNED OVER TO MR
MR MEDINA. YOU WANNA GO. YOU SEE
. WHAT ABOUT YOUR. JUST WANTED
TO MENTION- THE BILL THAT I HI
AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY- HAVE
INTRODUCED TO INCREASE OF
FUNDING AT THE UC ARE AND UC
MERCED CAMPUS- AS WE'VE SPOKEN
ABOUT MANY TIMES HERE OF BOTH UC
RIVERSIDE- ESPECIALLY UC
RIVERSIDE HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
UNDER FUNDED AND- PER STUDENT OF
FUNDING SO THE BILL THAT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY AND I OR
INTRODUCING IS TO TRY TO
ATTEMPT. TO- FIX THAT THAT
CONDITION AND TO BRING BOTH OF
THOSE TWO CAMPUSES UP TO THE
SAME KIND OF LEVEL OF FUNDING.
AS THE OTHER- AS SOMETIMES
REFERRED TO FLAGSHIP CAMPUSES
SO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND- GRAY
AND I INTRODUCED A BILL TO- FIND
YOU SEE OUR- AND UC MERCED WITH
CLOSE TO ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME MONEY. AND I'M GONG
I'M GOING MONEY AS WELL- WE HAD
THE CHANCELLOR'S OF BOTH YOU SEE
OUR AND UC MERCED HERE
YESTERDAY- I THINK IT'S- PAST
TIME THAT ALL CAMPUSES BE-
TREATED EQUALLY AND I KNOW THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT AND YOU
SEE. HAS BEEN WORKING ON IT FOR
MANY YEARS- UNDER THE PAST TWO
PRESIDENTS- WITH THREE BENCHING
BUT I THINK MY BILL AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGREES BILL WILL GO A
LONG WAY. PROVIDE EQUAL
TREATMENT TO ALL CAMPUSES AND
ESPECIALLY AS YOU POINTED OUT TO
THE CAMPUSES THAT HAVE THE
HIGHEST A MINORITY- ENROLLMENT-
BEING UC RIVERSIDE AND UC MERCED
TO JUST WANT TO PUT THAT ON YOUR
RADAR- AND PERHAPS ASK FOR A
COMMENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF OUR CAMPUSES-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF
OUR STUDENTS AND THE CAMPUSES
THAT HAVE TRADITIONALLY HAD
SLIGHTLY LESS FUNDING PER
STUDENT THAT OTHER CAMPUSES AS
YOU MENTIONED THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN TRYING TO
CORRECT FOR THE INEQUITIES
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM. FIRST BY
IMPLEMENTING BREED BENCHING
WHICH SOUGHT TO GIVE EACH
CAMPUS- THE SAME DOLLARS PER
STUDENT. IN ORDER TO CREATE
SOME- SIMILARITY BETWEEN THE
FUNDING LEVELS OF OUR CAMPUSES
AND WE ARE NOW ARE PRETTY
FINDING THAT FORMULA TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT- WITHIN THE DOLLARS
PER STUDENT BECAUSE WE
PREVIOUSLY USED A WEIGHTED
AVERAGE OF STUDENTS. WITHIN
DOLLARS PER STUDENT THAT NO
CAMPUS AS MORE THAN 5% OF HELLO
OTHER CAMPUSES AND WHAT THEY
RECEIVE OUR STUDENTS. WELL I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH YOU- ON ON MY BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR THANK
YOU MR MEDINA. THAT'S A NICE-
SEGUE TO THE ENVIRONMENT ISSUE
BECAUSE WHILEWHY MR MEDINA'S
PROPOSAL MAKES SO MUCH SENSE FOR
MORE INVOLVEMENT AT RIVERSIDE
AND ALSO UC MERCED. IS THAT SIR
WE HAVE PLENTY OF ROOM IN
CAPACITY TO GROW I WILL NOTE
THOSE ARE CITIES WE DON'T HAVE.
YOU KNOW NIMBY NEIGHBORS
FIGHTING IN SUING TO. TO HALTS-
EXPANSION THAT THOSE UC CAMPUSES
SO THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING
VERY PROMISING. JUST WANNA GO
BACK- TO THIS DAY AND I'M NOT
GONNA YOU KNOW BE DONE THIS
ISSUE AT AND YOU KNOW. THAT
THERE'S THAT. DISAPPOINTMENT IS
TO UNDERSTATE THE REFLECTION
THAT WE'RE NOT GETTING THE SEVEN
THOUSAND NEW STUDENTS THIS FALL
AND I KNOW YOU SEE SAYING WELLS
THIS WEEK. WE HAD FIVE FOR
SEVERAL THOUSAND WAITING QUITE
COUNTS LAST FEW YEARS WE DIDN'T.
WE DIDN'T DO THAT. YOU KNOW THE
YOU KNOW THE UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW MANY OTHER WHERE SO WE'RE
GONNA CANNOT CONTRIBUTE THOSE TO
THE NEW AND THEN ONLY DO A
COUPLE THOUSAND. THIS YEAR SO WE
WANT TO KEEP. ENGAGING IN THE
NEXT FW MONTHS. AND IT'S HARD
TO TURN ON THE WATER SPEAK IT
NOW SO YES SEVEN THOUSAND ARE
GOING TO BE THIS FALL FROM THE
SLICK LESSON. YOU KNOW A ROUGHLY
ABOUT- SIX OR SO MONTHS AWAY SO-
BUT- YOU KNOW AT THE MINIMUM THE
SEMESTER THIS SEMESTER AFTER
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY
WANT TO FOCUS ON- SO THE
QUESTION IS HOW. HOW CAN AT THIS
POINT. HOW CAN LOOKING YOU SEE.
HELLO SECOND. WHAT CAN YOU SEE
PUT OUT THERE AS FAR AS BEING
MORE IN LINE WITH THE
LEGISLATORS LEGISLATIVE AND
GOVERNOR'S EXPECTATIONS LAST
SUMMER WE PASS THE BUDGET FOR
THIS SEVEN THOUSAND NUMBER I
HEARD YOU EARLIER SAY TWELVE
HUNDRED PLUS FIVE HUNDRED MORE
YOU'D ADD ON FOR SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED AND I THINK LAST WEEK
WE'RE TALKING TWENTY FIVE IN THE
TO SELL I'M NOT SURE WHAT THAT
IS THEIR CELL. MAYBE ADDRESS
THAT SIMPLE START WITH THAT
FIRST THING. BUT THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
THE- TWELVE HUNDRED PLUS THE
FIVE HUNDRED- WAS INTENDED TO-
LOOK AT THE NEW STUDENTS WITHOUT
THE NON RESIDENT REPLACE TOUCH
WITH THE NON RESIDENT PLACEMENT
IT WOULD ACTUALLY BE TWO
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS
WHILE PREVIOUSLY WE HAD
DISCUSSED TWO THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED STUDENTS YEAH. THIS FALL
YEAH AND THAT OF COURSE IS VERY
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S GREAT NEWS
AND OF COURSE OUR FOCUS A 100%
IS CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS- WE
HEARD THIS LOUD AND CLEAR YES
YOUR HONOR FLOOR DEBATE ABOUT
BERKELEY THAT'S OUR TOP TOP
PRIORITY MAKE NO MISTAKE IN
PEOPLE HAVE QUALMS OF THAT YOU
KNOW THAT'S WHAT OUR-
CONSTITUENTS- DEMAND OF US- YOU
KNOW BUT IT'S REALLY ONLY
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED NEW SLOTS NEW
SPACES BECAUSE NINE HUNDRED WORK
RE SHUFFLING FROM YOU KNOW NON
RESIDENTS WHO ARE LEAVING THE
SYSTEM BRING ANY. SO THIS
HUNDRED KIND AND NEWS NEWS SLOTS
AND WHY THIS MATTER SO MUCH AS
GOES BACK TO YOUR COMMENTS FIVE
MINUTES AGO WE HAVE THE LARGEST
EVER. QUALIFIED APPLICANT POOL-
SO WE HAVE A RECORD NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO HAVE AMAZING
GRADES. I'M OF COURSE YOU KNOW
THE TEST SCORES AREN'T THERE
ANYMORE THE SAT BEING PHASED OUT
WE APPROPRIATELY. BUT GPA AND
CLASS RANK. AND THEIR INDIVIDUAL
APPLICATIONS ALL MATTER WE HAVE
AMAZING APPLICANTS YOU JUST YOU
KNOW DON'T HAVE SPACE AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE GONNA PUSH. AS
HARD AS WE CAN. TO APPROPRIATELY
GET AS MANY STUDENTS TEN ALONG
WITH OTHER HAS BEEN ONLY TO
ADDRESS. FACILITIES YOU KNOW
CLASSROOM SPACE LAB SPACE AND
YOU KNOW THE ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM WITH THE DEBATE WITH
BERKELEY IS HOUSING SO WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE CERTAINLY ON THAT
WORKING WITH THE UNIVERSITY ON
THAT. SO- THE QUESTION IS. HOW
CAN THE UC HELP US ACHIEVE LAST
YEAR'S GOAL WHICH IS THE SEVEN
THOUSAND NUMBER ABOVE WHICH YOU
ARTICULATED EARLIER IN YOUR
PRESENTATION HOW CAN WE KIND OF
BRIDGE THAT. THE GAP HERE
BETWEEN US. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SIR- BRIDGING THE GAP
FOR FALL TWENTY TWENTY TWO MAY
NOT BE FULLY POSSIBLE. BECAUSE
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO HIRE
ENOUGH INSTRUCTORS TO TEACH SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS. ARE AT BUT WE
DO HAVE ENOUGH APPLICANTS INTO
THE UC SYSTEM TO INCREASE OUR
ADMISSIONS BEYOND THE- OF TWO
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED THAT I
ALREADY DISCUSSED. OF CLOSE THE
BUDGET HAS NOT YET BEEN
FINALIZED AND UNIVERSITY DOESN'T
YET HAVE THAT INVOLVEMENT
FUNDING. WE CAN'T START HIRING
FACULTY BECAUSE WE HAVE NO
FUNDING TO BRING THEM ON BOARD
UNTIL- JULY FIRST WHEN THE
BUDGET WILL BECOME LAW. SO
BECAUSE OF THAT WE'RE UNABLE TO
START THE HIRING PROCESS FOR THE
FACULTY THAT WE WOULD NEED FOR
THE SIX THOUSAND NEW STUDENTS-
WE MAY BE ABLE TO I KNOW WE CAN
IN ROLE THAT MANY STUDENTS OVER
THREE YEARS. AND THERE MAY BE
WAYS TO ACCELERATE IT TO TWO
YEARS. YES THAT'S A GOOD POINT
SO I KNOW THERE'S DEBATE AND LA
I WAS SAYING WE SHOULDN'T GIVE
YOU ALL THE MONEY FOR THAN SIXTY
TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT NECESSARILY GOING ON
ROLE THEN- IF WE DID KEEP IT IN
THERE WHAT WHAT WITH THE
COMMITMENT BE THAT YOU'D BE ABLE
TO HAVE THEM. THE FOLLOWING YEAR
SO THE- TWENTY TWENTY THREE YOU
SEE YOU YOU WOULD HAVE THE MONEY
THERE JULY ONE- AND FRANKLY WE
THINK YOU COULD HAVE STARTED
MAKING THE HIRING DECISIONS IN
THE SPRING YOU GET THE MONEY A
FEW MONTHS LATER IN JUNE ANYWAY
BUT WE- KIND OF. WE CROSS THAT.
BRIDGE SO WE CAN'T GO BACK HERE.
SO WHAT TYPE OF COMMITMENT WILL
BE HAVE FOR TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TO THE END TO THE ENTIRE. SIXTY
TWO HUNDRED NUMBER. FOR TWENTY
TWENTY THREE THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD UTILIZE THE 5%
BASED BUDGET ALLOCATION PROPOSED
IN THE MULTI YEAR COMPACT. TO
ENROLL AN ADDITIONAL TWO
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES. FOOTBALL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE NO I GET THAT IT
I'M SAYING THAT IF WE GIVE YOU
THE ENTIRE MONEY THAT SLATED THE
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL FROM THE
GOVERNOR WHICH IS FUNDING FOR
THE SIXTY TWO HUNDRED. AND YOU
SAID YOU WE CAN'T DO IT FOR THIS
FALL'S TOO LATE- WE COMMIT TO
HAVE THAT ENTIRE NUMBER FOR
TWENTY TWENTY THREE IF WE FIND
THE ENTIRE AMOUNT. THIS THIS
THIS YEAR. WE ARE HOPING TO
UTILIZE STEVE FUNDING PROPOSED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TOWARDS
OUR CURRENT OVER TARGET.
STUDENTS YEAH SO WE WOULD NEED A
FURTHER INCREASE IN FUNDING IN
ORDER TO. INCREASE ENROLLMENT
BEYOND THE TWO THOUSAND THAT
WERE ALREADY COMMITTED TO TAKE
ON IN FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE CATCHES SO LET'S JUST STOP
RIGHT HERE SO I GET THAT I'M IN
TOTAL AGREEMENT. AND HE'S NOT
HERE RIGHT NOW BUT I TALKED TO.
BUDGET CHAIR TEAM JUST BEFORE
THE HEARING STARTED AND WE WANT
TO PUT ON THE RECORD THAT. THAT
WE'RE WE ARE WE ARE WILLING TO
REVERSE THE DECISION THAT WAS
MADE. DURING THE RECESSION.
WHERE WE DON'T TRUE UP AFTER THE
YEAR TO FULLY FUND. MINISTERED
AS A SALAD BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S
ART ON ADMISSIONS WHO ACTUALLY
SHOWS UP. SO WE SO WE GET THAT.
WE WOULD RATHER YOU KNOW ERR ON
THE SIDE OF. OF HAVING MORE
STUDENTS AND PAPERS TO ANSWER
SHOW UP THEN THEN THERE THAN THE. REVERSE SO- HOW CAN WE WORK
TOGETHER. TO DO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING WHICH IS FUNDS THAT THE
SPIKE THAT YOU GOT DURING THE
KOBE LAST TWO YEARS I KNOW IT
WAS HARD YOU CAN PREDICT TWO
SHOWING UP AND ADMISSIONS AND
ENROLLMENT IS THAT. AGAIN AN ART
NOT A SCIENCE YOU NOT ALWAYS
CERTAINLY PRECISE IT TOOK. TWO
YEARS TO FIGURE OUT THAT THE
MATHEMATICAL ERRORS WHICH IS YOU
KNOW THE PROBLEM WARRANT TODAY
ITSELF THAT'S ON YOUR ALL AND
BUT WE UNDERSTAND IF. WE GET THE
GOOD NEWS IS WE HAVE MORE PEOPLE
ON THESE CAMPUSES SO YES. SO HOW
CAN WE FULLY FUND THOSE AND GET
THE SEVEN THOUSAND THAT WE- HAD
OUR DESIRE TO. WHAT DO WE NEED
TO DO TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN. SO
AT. THE NUMBERS OF STUDENTS THAT
ARE IN THERE TODAY. AND THE
SEVEN THOUSAND BY THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. WHAT IS TO
HAPPEN TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
ABOUT THAT WOULD BE- THAT WOULD
BE A LOT OF EXERCISE DO THAT SO
EACH ONE THOUSAND NEW STUDENTS
WOULD COST APPROXIMATELY- ELEVEN
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
THE UC SYSTEM TO TAKE ON- AND
SINCE WE'RE PROPOSING TO TAKE ON
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND TWO THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED. AND FALL TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- THAT IT'S GOT US TO FOUR
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED SO THE
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS WOULD NEED
TO BE FUNDED FROM ADDITIONAL
FUNDS I GET THAT BUT AGAIN FORTY
SIX HUNDRED IS WAY LESS THAN
THAT. SEVEN THOUSAND THAT WE DID
AND THESE PRESS RELEASES ON LAST
SUMMER TO HIGHLIGHT WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO IN THE INTERIM
YOU'RE SAYING OH BY THE WAY
CALIFORNIA WE OVER AND ROLL
THESE OTHER STUDENTS WE NEED TO
TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES AND SO.
WE'RE SAYING WE'RE WE AGREE WITH
THAT WE ARE GOING TO WORK TO
FULLY FUND THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS YOU HAVE TO KIND OF
LIKE A TRUE UP AFTER THE YEAR
HOW MANY WE HAVE WILL FULLY FUND
THE MARGINAL COST THOSE ACTUAL
STUDENTS. BUT WE STILL WANT TO
NOT LOSE SIGHT ON. THE HIGHER
NUMBER AND WHY DOES THIS MATTER
BECAUSE IT GOES BACK TO YOUR
STATEMENT ABOUT THE RECORD
NUMBER OF APPLICANTS. IS BACK
THE FACT THAT. EMPLOYERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SAY MANY MORE COLLEGE
GRADUATES FOR TO FILL THE JOBS
OF TODAY AND TOMORROW- YOU KNOW
WE KNOW THAT THIS REALLY
MATTERS. AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
PUSH- TO THE HELP MAKE THIS
HAPPEN. THANK YOU FOR THAT SIR I
HEAR THAT YOU WANT TO GIVE
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
WHO HAVE WORKED SO HARD TO GET
THE GRADES TO GET INTO UC- WE
WILL WORK WITH YOU TO SEE HOW
MANY MORE SUDENTS WE COULD.
ENROLL TO REACH THAT SIX
THOUSAND STUDENT GOALS SOONER-
WILL NEED APPROXIMATELY. TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OR SO IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS. FOR THOSE FOR
THAT BRIDGE BETWEEN THE FOUR
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND A SEVEN
THOUSAND THAT. WE'RE DISCUSSING
NOW. AND WE WILL WORK TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN I DON'T SEE THAT IS
THE IS THE ISSUE. HI MR LEGIA
COMES YOUR QUESTION.
OKAY WHAT WILL CERTAINLY- MOVE
ON HOLD THIS ISSUE BUT JUST TO
SUMMARIZE WE'RE GOING TO
COORDINATE TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
WE TRUE AT AND FOCUS ON THE
EXISTING STUDENTS AND PUT THE
RESOURCES IN THIS BUDGET TO
ACHIEVE THAT THE TO ACHIEVE THE
GOAL THAT WE OUTLINED- FOR THAT
FOR THAT SEVEN THOUSAND NUMBER
TO YOU KNOW. MAXIMIZE
PARTICIPATION OF OUR INCOMING
FRESHMAN. AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU- SO WITH
THAT WE WILL GO ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO WHICH IS THE BASE
BUDGET THIS IS THE GOVERNOR'S
OVERALL BUDGET PROPOSAL WITH THE
BASE BUDGET THE INCREASE OF 5%
FOR YOU SEE CORPORATIONS- WHICH
DOES INCLUDE- A 1% ENROLLMENT
GROWTH AS WELL. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES GOOD MORNING JACK
SWELLED FROM FINANCE- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REFLECTS THE
COMPACT BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
CONTACT PROVIDES CONSISTENT
PREDICTABLE SUPPORT TO YOU STATE
THAT WILL SUPPORT THE
UNIVERSITY'S CORE OPERATIONS AND
A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT TO
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A 5%
BASED BUDGET INCREASE OF TWO AND
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO THE RESOURCES
PROVIDED TO SUPPORT ENROLLMENT
WHICH WE DISCUSSED EARLIER IN
THIS HEARING. THE CONTACT CALLS
FOR AN ANNUAL 5% INCREASE
THROUGH. TWENTY TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN- PROVIDED YOU SEE
ADVANCES SHARED GOALS- DESIGNED
INCREASE ACCESS ADVANCE EQUITY
WRITTEN REDUCE COSTS TO STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. AND PETS
COLLABORATION AND ALIGNMENT WITH
THEIR INSTITUTIONS AND WORKFORCE
NEEDS. HAVE A RESTAURANTS AFTER
MICHAEL. AT PRESENT. THANK YOU
LA UP- BEFORE WE GET INTO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS I JUST WANNA.
NOTE THAT IN ADDITION TO THE
PROPOSED BASED INCREASE UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET YOU SEE IS
PLANNING TO INCREASE TUITION AS
PART OF A MULTI YEAR TUITION
PLAN YOU SEE BORDER IT'S A
DOCTOR- LAST YEAR. BUT OF OUR
NOSE THAT WAS ESTIMATED TO BRING
IT APPROXIMATELY FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS SO- COMBINED
WITH THE PROPOSED BASED INCREASE
THAT WOULD GIVE YOU SEE ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN NEED BASED
SUPPORT. TO WORK WITH THAT
COVER. CORE OPERATIONAL COST
INCREASES. WEAPON OF YOUR GENDER
DESCRIBES OUR ANALYSIS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS- ANALYSIS IS
SOMETHING THAT COMMITTEE AS PER
SE MANY TIMES IN THE PAST AS- OF
THE COMMITTEE IS NOTED- YOU KNOW
BATES INCREASES ARE. SORT OF A
LONG STANDING PRACTICE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO COMPOSE. AND
INVESTORS WE'VE FOUND BATES
INCREASE APPROACH TO BE NOT A
GREAT. APPROACH TO BUDGETING. IT
A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY IN LACKS
A CLEAR RATIONALE CONNECTION TO
ACTUAL COSTS THAT THE-
UNIVERSITIES ATTENDING THIS
IMPORTANT GIVE THE LEGISLATURE
VERY LITTLE INFORMATION AS TO
WHAT IT IS PACIFIC WAS SUPPORTED. WITH THE AUGMENTATION. I WOULD
RECOMMEND A CONNECTING ROOM TO
MORE SPECIFIC AS TO. FOR EXAMPLE
LET'S COULD CANNOT DOCUMENT. TO
ACTUAL COSTING THAT THE
UNIVERSITY AND- AT THE CURRENT
IN THE BUDGET. THANKS AS DEBT
SERVICE OPERATING EXPENSES
EQUIPMENT EMPLOYEE BENEFIT
INCREASES AN EMPLOYEE'S SALARY
INCREASES. NOW ONE THING I WANT
TO KNOW ABOUT OUR ASSESSMENT IS
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE HARD
RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO THE EXACT
LEVEL OF AUGMENTATION THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD PROVIDE TO
THE UNIVERSITY THAT'S
ALTERNATELY SOMETHING THAT
LEGISLATURE ONE A WEIGHT BASED
ON ITS- GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES
. IN FACT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
AFTER REVIEWING UC'S- COST
PRESSURES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MIKE. THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
INCREASES WARRANTED WE ESTIMATE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WOULD
SUPPORT UC'S. FIXING FOR
OPERATING COST INCREASES. AND
ALSO SUPPORT BY NEARLY 3%
INCREASE IN POINTS OUT. HOW TO
REQUEST MIGHT HAVE A DIFFERENT A
TERMINATION OF MY DETERMINE THAT
A HIGHER AUGMENTATIONS WARRANTED
DUE TO. YOU KNOW HOW INFLATION
PRESSURES THAT COULD PUT
PRESSURE TO. INCREASE US
SALARIES FOR EMPLOYEES OR
ALTERNATIVELY YOU COULD
DETERMINE THAT A LOWER OF
MAGICIANS WANTED. HELLO FOR
BASED ON THE STATE COULD PASS
BASED ON THE THAT YOU SEE IS
BERKELEY IS. PRETTY COMPETITIVE
IN TERMS OF ITS COMPENSATION
PACKAGES FOR EMPLOYEES HER POINT
IS THAT THOSE SHOULD FACTOR
SHOULD BE THIS OR BASIS FOR-
LEGISLATIVE DETERMINATION. NOT
ARBITRARY THESE INCREASES
DETERMINE ANY GRIEVANCE BETWEEN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND BOB
UNIVERSITY. QUARTERFINAL WE JUST
WANT TO STRESS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD NOT FEEL
BEHOLDEN TO CONNECT TO THE MULTI
YEAR AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE LARGE
FRAME THE- ADMINISTRATION OF THE
UNIVERSITY. I JUST BECAUSE THAT
REMAINS RICH BETWEEN THEM THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD STILL RETAIN
ITS- AND YOU WILL OF AUTHORITY
TO REVIEW THE BUDGET PROPOSALS
AND THE SPECIAL PROPOSALS EACH
YEAR. BASED ON THE DIFFERENT
FACTORS THAT PRESENTED EACH
YEAR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU OF THE UNIVERSITY IS
THANKFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED MULTI YEAR FUNDING TO
SUPPORT OPERATIONS AND
INVOLVEMENT GROWTH THE PROPOSED
5% ANNUAL BASE BUDGET INCREASES
FOR FIVE YEARS WOULD PROVIDE
STABILITY AND SUPPORT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY AS WE UNDERTAKE
IMPORTANT AN AMBITIOUS GOALS FOR
ACCESS EQUITY AND AFFORDABILITY
. PARTNERSHIP THE UNIVERSITY HAS
HAD WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR IN RECENT YEARS HAS
ALLOWED US TO ENROLL THOUSANDS
OF NEW CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES
INCREASED AVAILABILITY OF
MEDICAL EDUCATION AND CONDUCT
RESEARCH ON ISSUES IMPACTING THE
LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS IN EVERY
PART OF THE STATE. FROM
AGRICULTURE TO HEALTH THE
CHILDREN'S LEARNING LOSS. THESE
ACHIEVEMENTS HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR CHOSE TO INVEST IN
HIGHER EDUCATION. WE ASK THAT
YOU CONTINUE THIS PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORTING OUR SHARED GOALS FOR
THE UNIVERSITY'S EXCELLENCE. WE
HAVE BEEN LIVING WITH A
CHALLENGING PANDEMIC FOR TWO
YEARS OUR FACULTY AND STUDENTS
HAVE ADJUSTED TO CHANGING
INSTRUCTIONAL MODALITIES AND OUR
STAFF HAVE KEPT THE CAMPUS
OPERATIONS AND SERVICES GOING
STRONG. OUR MEDICAL CENTERS HAVE
TENDED TO PATIENTS PROVIDED
VACCINES AND CONDUCTED RESEARCH
ON COBIT AND ITS IMPACTS THE
ENTIRE UNIVERSITY COMMUNITY HAS
RESPONDED ADMIRABLY AND CONTINUE
TO CONTRIBUTE POSITIVELY TO
CALIFORNIA. THE STATE'S FISCAL
AND POLICY CONTRIBUTIONS THE
UNIVERSITY HELPED WITH THIS
FLEXIBILITY DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE STATE'S
ECONOMY AS THE THIRD LARGEST
EMPLOYER IN THE STATE WITH AN
ESTIMATED TOTAL BUDGET OF OVER
FORTY FOUR BILLION IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. UNIVERSITY
PROVIDES EDUCATION RESEARCH AND
PUBLIC SERVICES THAT TOUCH ON
THE LIVES OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
TODAY I WILL DISCUSS OUR CORE
FUNDS BUDGET WITH YOU THIS IS
THE COMPONENT OF THE
UNIVERSITY'S BUDGET THAT FUNDS
ARE CAMPUS OPERATIONS. INCLUDING
INSTRUCTION. WHAT'S THE STATE
CHEN FUND TUITION AND FEES NON
RESIDENTS OF. TO AND A FEW
SMALLER FUNDS. THE CORE FUNDS
BUDGET FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
IS ESTIMATED AT TEN POINT FIVE
BILLION. OR BILLION OF THIS CORE
OPERATING BUDGET IS PROVIDED US
ONGOING STATE GENERAL FUND.
ANOTHER ONE BILLION COMES IN
DIRECTLY FROM STATE IN THE FORM
OF CAL GRANT TO MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIPS TO COVER STUDENTS
TUITION. THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE BUDGET PROPOSES
FOUR POINT THREE BILLION AN
ONGOING STATE GENERAL FUND AND
TWO HUNDRED NINETY FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME FUNDS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
TOTAL BUDGET OF FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION THE PROPOSED 5% BASED
BUDGET INCREASE WOULD PROVIDE TO
UNIVERSITY WITH TWO HUNDRED
POINT FIVE MILLION. IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE TO SUSTAIN
CAMPUS OPERATIONS AND HELP
UNIVERSITY UNDERTAKE POLICY
CALLS FOR ACCESS EQUITY
AFFORDABILITY. AND COLLABORATION
WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND CSU.
CAMPUS OPERATING COST INCREASES
THAT THE UNIVERSITY FACES
INCLUDE CONTRACTUALLY COMMITTED
REPRESENTED LABOR SALARY
INCREASES DEBT SERVICE ON OUR
BUILDINGS FACULTY OF POLICY
COVERED STAFF INCREASES AND
GENERAL OPERATING INFLATIONARY
PRESSURES. THE PROPOSED BASED
BUDGET INCREASES FOR THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS COUPLED WITH THE
UNIVERSITY'S COVERT BASS TUITION
ADJUSTMENTS WILL PROVIDE THE
UNIVERSITY WITH RESOURCE ABILITY
TO GROW ENROLLMENT RESPONSIBLY.
MAKE FURTHER PROGRESS ON CLOSING
GRADUATION GAPS AND BEGIN
OFFERING DEBT FREE EDUCATION
OPTIONS. IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE COURT BASED TUITION AND
FEES ARE ESTIMATED TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL FORTY FIVE MILLION IN
OPERATING REVENUE. AND THIRTY
THREE POINT. SEVEN MILLION IN
FINANCIAL AID. RECOGNIZING
ACCESS MUST BE PARTNERED WITH
SUCCESS THE REGION'S HAS SET OF
GOAL AND OUTLINED IMPLEMENTATION
STRATEGIES FOR CLOSING
GRADUATION GAPS. WHILE THE CARD
FOR YOUR OVERALL GRADUATION RATE
IS SEVENTY TWO POINT 6% THE FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION RATE FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS IS SIXTY
TWO POINT THREE PERCENT. THE
UNIVERSITY WANTS TO ENHANCE
STUDENT ACADEMIC PREPARATION
ADVISING TUTORING AND BOLSTER
ANALYTICAL TOOLS TO ALLOW FOR
EARLY ACADEMIC INTERVENTION AND
SUPPORT INNOVATIONS IN
INSTRUCTION. INSTRUCTIONAL
DELIVERY METHODS FOR CLOSING
THIS GRADUATION GAP. IN THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE LEGISLATURE DEVELOP NEW
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS TO REDUCE
THE COST OF HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
STUDENTS. THE UNIVERSITY SHARES
THIS GOAL OF DEBT FREE EDUCATION
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR. PRESIDENT DRAKE HAS
DISCUSSED HIS INTENT TO MOVE
TOWARDS DEBT FREE EDUCATION AND
ASSISTANCE OF STATE AND FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS WE WILL
BEGIN MAKING PROGRESS ON THIS
GOAL. THE STATE'S INVESTMENTS
FOR FINANCIAL AID GROW SO WILL
OUR PROGRAMS TO OFFER ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE TO OUR STUDENTS THESE
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS COMBINED
WITH THE STABILITY PROVIDED BY
THE UNIVERSITY'S COHORT BASED
TUITION. WILL PROVIDE ASSURANCE
TO OUR STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES THAT. THEY CAN AFFORD
HIGHER EDUCATION. ORDERS BY ALSO
ESTABLISH GOALS FOR THE YEAR.
COLLAB WITH COLLEGES AND CSU THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN INCREASING INTER SEGMENTAL
COLLABORATION IN RECENT YEARS
WHAT TWENTY ONE THE STOPPAGE
TRANSFER PATHWAYS FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TO UC. STUDENT ACADEMIC
PREPARATION AN EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS TO PREPARE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WERE
TRANSFERRED TO CSU OR UC AND
WORKING WITH STATE PARTNER
AGENCIES ON A BLUEPRINT FOR THE
CRADLE TO CAREER SYSTEM. THE
COLLABORATION GOALS OUTLINED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCREASES
COLLABORATION AND LEVERAGE
DISTRICTS OF EACH PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENT. WITH THE
SHARED GOALS IN MIND THE
UNIVERSITY OF REQUEST FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BASED BUDGET INCREASE
OF 5% THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR M-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. TRY MISTER
LEE NO I BACK TO- THE ENROLLMENT
GROWTH ISSUE ON THE BASE BUDGET
SO THIS WOULD THIS IS- THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE GOVERNOR IS
FIVE YEARS PER YEAR OVER A OF YEARS AND OF COURSE
THAT'S THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
AND IT'S AT STATE BUDGET WHICH
HAS TO BE AGREED UPON YEAR BY
YEAR FOR THE LEGISLATURE BUT-
YOU KNOW I ASSUME AB A STRONG
APPETITE EVERY YEAR FOR THE
LEGISLATURE- THERE ALWAYS. HAS
BEEN RELAYED TO FULLY FUNDING
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. I
HOW DO WE- CALCULATE. HOW MUCH
OF THIS WOULD WOULD WOULD GO OF
THE 5% TO FUNDS IN ROMAN GROWTH
IS THAT AUTOMATICALLY BUILT IN
OR IS THAT A FLEXIBLE NUMBER
EACH YEAR WHAT WHAT WHAT'S YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS
ARRANGEMENT ALASKA THE UC TO
START WITH THAT. THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA THINKS THE 5% WILL
COVER THE ENROLLMENT GROWTH OF
1% WHICH WILL BE APPROXIMATELY
TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS ANNUALLY
AT A COST OF ABOUT TWENTY THREE
MILLION. COMING OUT OF THAT 5%
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS. THAT'S RIGHT
ANNUAL GROSS OF 1% SO EACH YEAR
BUILDING ON THE NEXT ONE TWO
THOUSAND THERE'S SLOTS ANNUALLY.
OKAY SO TWO THOUSAND SLOTS
ANNUALLY. IS WELL OVER TEN YEARS
THAT'S ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND. SO
IF WE IF WE- FUNDED THE THAT IT
INCREASE ENROLLMENT LIKE WE
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER- THIS IS
LIKE COMPOUNDING NUMBER SO HOW
HOW- WILLING IS THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM WHY THIS GOES BACK TO
YOUR LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT
PLANS A KIND OF A- MICROCOSM OF
THE DEBATE WITH UC BERKELEY- HOW
READY IS THE UNIVERSITY ABLE TO-
TO GET TO THAT TWENTY THOUSAND
NUMBER BY TWENTY THIRTY. OR EVEN
THIRTY THOUSAND. WHERE WHERE
PREPARE TO GET TO TWENTY
THOUSAND NEW STUDENTS BY TWENTY
THIRTY WHICH INCLUDES. SIXTEEN
THOUSAND UNDERGRADUATES A
COMPONENT OF WHICH WOULD OF THE
REPLACEMENT OF NON RESIDENTS
WITH RESIDENTS. AND IS THAT IS
THAT NUMBER. A REACH ABOVE THAT
IS THAT THE CONSTRAINTS BASED
UPON MONEY OR IS IT BASED UPON
YOUR CAMPUS IS NOT IN HAVING THE
CAPACITY WITH. SPACE TO LAND AND
SO FORTH SO IF THE IF THERE WAS
A MEETING OF THE MINDS OF DESIRE
TO GO TO THIRTY THOUSAND WHICH
MISTER KING AND I HAVE SPOKEN TO
MISTER DRAKE ABOUT. AND HE
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT AND CERTAINLY
SAID THAT THEY WOULD TRY TO GO
NORTH OF TWENTY THOUSAND WHAT
ARE SOME OF THAT CONSTRAINTS TO
SUCH. A GOAL TODAY. TODAY THE
CONSTRAINTS WOULD BE THE- NUMBER
OF ACADEMIC SPACE ON THE
CAMPUSES AND THE FACT THAT IT
TAKES ABOUT THREE YEARS TO
CONSTRUCT A NEW ACADEMIC
FACILITY OUR LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLANS WHICH ARE
GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS FOR THE
CAMPUSES THAT INCLUDE ENROLLMENT
AS A COMPONENT OF THOSE PLANS
WOULD ALLOW FOR EXPANSION OF UP
TO FORTY THOUSAND. FIVE NEW
STUDENTS ON OUR CAMPUSES BY
APPROXIMATELY- TWENTY THIRTY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE DEPENDING ON
THE CAMPUS OF BUT THERE IS
DEFINITELY ROOM WITHIN THE
EXISTING LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT
PLANS FOR THE CAMPUS IS TO GROW.
THE CONSTRAINTS WITH THEN BE
BEING ABLE TO HIRE SUFFICIENT
NUMBERS OF FACULTY IN A TIMELY
MANNER AND BUILDING ACADEMIC
SPACE AND STUDENT HOUSING SO
THAT WHEN THE STUDENTS ARRIVE-
THEY HAVE SAFE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING NEAR THE CAMPUS YEAH.
YES SO WE'RE WORKING ON THE
HOUSING- AS AS WE KNOW AND WE'RE
FINDING ENROLLMENT GROWTH AS WE
KNOW SO IS THERE A THIRD MISSING
PIECES THEIR DESERT. NEEDED ONE
TIME FACILITIES MONEY OR DOES
THE DOES THE MONEY FOR THAT
ENROLLMENT GROWTH THE VIET. YOU
KNOW THE INTO ADDITIONAL
MARGINAL COSTS FOR EACH STUDENT
DOES THAT COVER YOUR YOU KNOW
YOUR STAFFING AND FACILITIES
NEEDS OR THE B. S. A SEPARATE
NEED. DEALING WITH CAPITAL
ISSUES. THERE WOULD BE A
SEPARATE NEED DEALING WITH
CAPITAL ISSUES FOR THE CAMPUSES
AND WHAT IS THE AND TIME'S UP
AND- I DON'T QUITE HAVE THAT IN
FRONT OF ME WE DO HAVE A ONE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
REQUEST FOR. THIS- BUDGET YEAR
OF THAT WOULD. HELP CAMPUS THAT
HAS- RENOVATE AND CONSTRUCT NEW
ACADEMIC SPACE AND PREPARATION
NEW STUDENTS I THINK THE
MAJORITY OF THAT IS- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS. NEEDED
RETROFITTING IN SIZE MAKE. THEN
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WHICH I
DON'T DIMINISH THAT BUT- WHAT'S
THE WHAT'S THE PLAN. FOR THE
UNIVERSITY TO ALLOW US TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU LOVE WE DON'T IT
COULD BE TWO YEARS AND- BACK- WE
DIDN'T QUITE GET THE NUMBER
RIGHT AND YOU KNOW THIS WAS IS
NOT PLEASANT GOING BACK IN
FIGHTING OVER. YOU KNOW THE
ACTUAL NUMBERS THAT WE WANT TO
HAVE FIRST IN ROME IT'S AND YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW WHY THIS MATTERS
BECAUSE THERE IS THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS ARE BEING TURNED AWAY.
AND WE HEAR FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS SO. WHAT DO WE NEED
TO DO TO PROPERLY PLAN FOR.
FIRST FACILITY IN CAPITAL NEEDS-
ON TOP OF HOUSING WHICH WE
ALREADY ARE ARE WORKING ON AND
FULLY FUNDING ENROLLMENT GROWTH
IS THERE IS THERE A PLAN THE
UNIVERSE IS GONNA PUT FOR TWO AT
A LONG TERM PLAN A CAPITAL PLAN
I KNOW YOU HAVE YOUR ONE POINT
SEVEN BUT AGAIN. IF I RECALL
LOOKING AT THAT A LOT OF THAT IS
YOUR EXISTING DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND SEISMIC NEEDS.
THAT'S NOT NEW THAT'S NOT NEW
NEWS YOU KNOW LAPSED INTO SPACE
. THE UNIVERSITY- HAS A FIVE
YEAR CAPITAL FINANCING PLAN.
THAT INCLUDES- ACADEMIC SPACE
THAT WE CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE
FUNDING PLANS TOWARDS- WE COULD
HAVE SOME OF THAT PLAN FUNDED BY
THE STATE. THROUGH A FUNDING
MECHANISM YET TO BE DETERMINED.
AND THUS MAKE ADDITIONAL SPACE
FOR THOSE STUDENTS. OKAY THANK
YOU SOUTHWESTERLY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST HAD A
QUESTION ABOUT THIS BECAUSE THIS
IS THIS BRINGS UP AN IMPORTANT
POINT SHARING'S IMPORTANT POINT
IS THAT YOU KNOW IN MY
EXPERIENCE WITH THE UC EVERY UC
CAMPUS TRIES CAN OPERATE IN ITS
OWN KINGDOM AND CREATE THEIR OWN
ALLERGY PEAS SO HOW AND THAT
REALLY GENERATES THEIR LONG TERM
EFFICIENCY OF HOW MANY SINCE
THEY CAN ENROLL HOW MUCH
ACADEMIC SPACE THEY CAN HAVE
RIGHT SO IN HAVING THAT PASSED
ON TO MY PAST EXPERIENCE IN THE
RECENT YEARS LIKE THAT. HOW HOW
MUCH COORDINATION IS THE UC
OFFICE FRESNO THE REGION'S
PUTTING PRESSURE ON ALL THE
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES BECAUSE OF
COURSE WE'RE ASKING. FOURTH
PERHAPS THIRTY THOUSAND NEW
STUDENTS ACROSS ENTIRE SYSTEM
RIGHT AND YOU NEED LEVEL
COORDINATION SAY WELL. SANTA
BARBARA YOU SHOULD TAKE THIS
MANY DAVID SHOULD TAKE THIS MANY
BERKELEY COULD TRY TO GROW IN
THIS LEVEL. ARE YOU ARE YOU ALL.
COORDINATING THAT KIND OF GROWTH
STRATEGY AN OLDER ALREADY PEAS
ARE YOU LETTING EACH INDIVIDUAL
CAMPUS PUSH ON THEIR OWN. AND
FIGURING OUT THAT WAY SO IS IT
LIKE A TOP DOWN SYSTEM OR A
BOTTOM UP SYSTEM RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CURRENTLY IT IS
A BIT MORE OF A BOTTOM UP.
SYSTEM WHERE EACH CAMPUS
DEVELOPS THEIR LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN. IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE COMMUNITY
WHERE THEY ARE BASED. AND
LOOKING AT WHAT THE
POSSIBILITIES ARE FOR THAT
CAMPUS AND HOW THEY WANT TO GROW
AND DEVELOP- ANNUALLY. THE UC
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT WORKS
WITH THE ADMISSIONS OFFICERS UP
EVERY CAMPUS. THE FIRST ASK THEM
HOW MANY STUDENTS THEY WANT TO
ENROLL AND THEN- FOR FALLING
SHORT OF THE LEGISLATIVELY SET
GOALS. WE WORK WITH THE CAMPUS
IS TO HAVE THEM INCREASE THOSE
NUMBERS TO. SEE WHO COULD TAKE
ON ADDITIONAL ENROLLMENT BUT
FIRST WE ALLOWED THE CAMPUS AS-
THEY TRY TO MAKE THAT CHOICE FOR
THEMSELVES. AND SEE IF IT THEN
ALIGNS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
GOALS. AND I DEFINITELY
UNDERSTAND EVERY CAMPUS AND
COMMUNITY EMBEDDED HAS OUR OWN
INDIVIDUAL WANTS AND NEEDS BUT I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'VE SEEN
OVER THE YEARS. WHY THERE'S
DIFFERENCE. NONRESIDENT ROMAN
THERE'S DIFFERENT STRATEGIES
HOUSING DIFFERENT STRATEGIES
EVERYWHERE BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
PURSUE WRITING A MORE CONSISTENT
STATEWIDE GOALS IS. GIVEN ALSO
THE MINISTRATION SEEMS TO HAVE
THAT AND I THINK YOU SEE SEEMS
TO WANT TO DO THAT SO I WOULD
URGE HOPEFULLY WE CAN COORDINATE
WITH US AT A MORE HIGHER LEVEL.
AND FIGURE OUT ITS NOT YOU KNOW
US PRESSING DOWN AND THEN YOU
HAVE TO DO THIS BUT LIKE HOW CAN
WE SHOULD LIVE TOGETHER. RATHER
THAN YOU ALL INDIVIDUALLY SAY I
ONLY WANT THIS MUCH- I CAN ONLY
DO THIS MUCH. AND THAT
COORDINATION I THINK HAS
RESULTED IN A MORE SCATTERED
APPROACH TO ENROLLMENT AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY WE'RE SEEING
SOME OF THE STRUGGLES WE HAVE.
SO I HOPE THAT YOU CAN WORK WITH
US THE LEGISLATURE TO REALLY
PRESS ON FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE
COORDINATE THESE GOALS RATHER
THAN HAVING THE CULTURE OF A-
INDIVIDUAL KINGDOMS I'VE KNOWN
YOU SEE TO BE. SUFFICIENT BUT I
JUST WANT TO HARP ON THAT AS I
THINK RELATED TO THE POINT THAT
CHEN RICCARDI WAS MAKING SO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HOWEVER
NONE THANK YOU WILL THAT HOLD
THIS ISSUE OR VAN FOOD PROCEED
NOW ISSUE NUMBER THREE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. GOOD MORNING JEFF
WALKED FROM THE FINANCE- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES A
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME.
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS IF YOU SEE.
THIS IS PART OF A YEARS LONG
TREND OF THE ADMINISTRATION
PROVIDING RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND IT
WASN'T UP TO OUR- PHILIPPINES
PRESENT THANK YOU. ALAIA. AS YOU
MINISTRATION NOTED- THIS
PROPOSAL REFLECTS THROUGH MANY
YEARS OF THE STATE PROVIDING ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. AND YOUR GENERALLY
OUR MESSAGE OVER THOSE YEARS HAS
BEEN THAT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
IS REASONABLE ESPECIALLY FOR ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR DRESSING
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
NOW PREVENTS- PROCESS COLLATION
IN FUTURE YEARS AND ALSO-
POTENTIALLY REDUCES THE RISK
FOR. DISRUPTION TO CAMPUS
OPERATIONS RESULTING FROM SYSTEM
FAILURES. THAT SAID IT- DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IS A- FAIRLY COMPLEX
ISSUE AND TO ILLUSTRATE THAT I
WOULD TURN YOUR ATTENTION TO
PAGE FOURTEEN. OF YOUR AGENDA.
THE SHORT TABLE AT THE BOTTOM OF
THAT PAGE FOURTEEN. AND PRESENTS
INFORMATION THAT YOU SEE
RECENTLY PROVIDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON ITS MAINTENANCE
NEEDS. AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE
TABLE YOU SEE ESTIMATES HAVING A
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG OF
SEVEN POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. AND ALSO ESTIMATES
HAVING A TEN YEAR RENEWAL NEED
OF TWELVE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT ROOMMATE IS
EFFECTIVELY THE ESTIMATE OF WHAT
USED TO WOULD HAVE TO SPEND TO
PREVENT THAT BACKLOG FROM
GROWING OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS
. IF YOU ANYONE IS NOT FOR THOSE
TEN YEARS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
THAT'S- OF NEARLY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. CAN YOU SEE SPEND
SYSTEM WIDE A LITTLE UNDER THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ON
MAINTENANCE. SUBSTANTIAL GAP
BETWEEN WHAT YOU SEE IS
CURRENTLY SPENDING AND- SORT OF
OVERALL DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS
THAT UC'S ESTIMATING. SO GIVEN
THAT INFORMATION YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TWO RECOMMENDATIONS FIRST
WHAT I WOULD RECOMMEND ADOPTING
THE PROPOSED OF FUNDS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE- BUT THEN SECONDLY
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
START THINKING LONGER TERM ABOUT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE SERVER
GIVEN THE COMPLEX ISSUES HERE.
NOW THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PROBABLY IS NOT
GOING TO RESULT IN THE END OF
THIS BUDGET CYCLE IT'LL PROBABLY
BE A MULTI YEAR PLAN WE CAN
START NOW COULD HELP THE
LEGISLATURE START THINKING
ABOUT. HOW TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
ON ON GOING BASIS HOW TO ENSURE
THAT UC'S ADEQUATELY PROVIDING
FUNDING TO ADDRESS ITS
MAINTENANCE NEEDS IN. DEVELOPING
A LONG TERM PLAN TO DEVELOP THE
MAINTENANCE HELLO MANY THE MEANS
BY FONG. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. I
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
THE GOVERNOR FOR PAST SUPPORT OF
THE UNIVERSITY'S DEPARTMENT AND
SUBURBS THE APPROPRIATIONS
RECEIVED IN PRIOR YEARS
INCLUDING THE FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSESSMENTS HAVE
HELP TO RESOLVE THE EMERGENCY
SYSTEM FAILURES AND HAVE A LOT
OF CAMPUS IS TO GAIN A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS. FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES ONE HUNDRED
MILLION AND ONE TIME INVESTMENTS
TO ADDRESS UC'S CRITICAL
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
CAMPUSES WILL UTILIZE THESE
FUNDS TO RENEW BUILDING SYSTEMS
ENSURE LIFE SAFETY STANDARDS AND
IMPROVE EERGY EFFICIENCY IN
CAMPUS BUILDINGS I REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSED
INVESTMENT. UNIVERSITIES CAPITAL
NEEDS ARE GREAT AND WE ARE
REQUESTING THE LEGISLATURE FOR A
TOTAL OF ONE POINT SIX BILLION
TO ADDRESS A COMBINATION OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY SEISMIC.%
FUNDS NEARLY A BILLION DOLLARS
WOULD GO TOWARD CLASSROOM
BUILDING RENEWABLE AND
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW ACADEMIC
SPACE THIS INVESTMENT IN
ACADEMIC FACILITIES IS IMPORTANT
TO ACCOMMODATE THE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THOUSAND NEW STUDENTS
WROTE THAT THE UNIVERSITY
PROPOSES TO UNDERTAKE BY TWENTY
THIRTY TO BE CALIFORNIA'S DEMAND
FOR DEGREES. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IN REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS OUR CAMPUSES
RECEIVE A THIRD OF THEIR ENERGY
FROM RENEWABLE ENERGY HOWEVER
SIX OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE THEIR
OWN NATURAL GAS HEATING POWER
PLANTS CONSTRUCTED IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES
DECOMMISSIONING THOSE FACILITIES
WILL TAKE TIME AND BE EXPENSIVE
BUT IT IS NECESSARY FOR THE
UNIVERSITY TO ACHIEVE
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN CARBON
EMISSIONS. BECAUSE OF THIS OUR
CAPITAL OUTLAY FUNDING REQUEST
INCLUDES CAMPUS DECARBONISATION
STUDIES. UNIVERSI OCCUPIES
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX MILLION GROSS SQUARE
FEET OF SPACE OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS CAMPUSES HAVE ENGAGED IN
EXTENSIVE PROCESS TO EVALUATE
THE COST OF CAPITAL OUTLAY FOR
NEW LEADS. AND DETERMINED THAT
SYSTEM WIDE CAMPUSES HAVE TWELVE
POINT THREE BILLION NEED WITHIN
EXISTING BUILDINGS. THIS AMOUNT
INCLUDES A SIZABLE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AND SEISMIC
RENOVATION OF OUR AGING
BUILDINGS. UNIVERSITY USES
INTEGRATED CAPITAL ASSET
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM OR I CAN'T TO
TRACK DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS. THE MOST CRITICAL
PROJECTS ARE LISTED AS READ IN
THE EYE CAMPS SYSTEM AND THE
UNIVERSITY CURRENTLY HAS ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION AND
READ CATEGORY DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS. THE
FUNDING PROVIDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE LAST BUDGET A
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR FOR
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE FISCAL
YEAR WILL UNIVERSITY MAKE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS ON
ADDRESSING THESE CRITICAL
PROJECTS. WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
UC MERCED UC CAMPUSES WERE
MAINLY CONSTRUCTED IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES OR EARLIER. USE
ORIGINAL BUILDINGS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NOW NEED
SIGNIFICANT REPAIRS AND
REPLACEMENTS WELL CAMPUS ROUTE.
KNOWN PROJECTS TO FOUR POINT
FIVE BILLION LIST THE PAST
USEFUL AGE INFRASTRUCTURE
RECORDED AN EYE CAMP COULD FAIL
AT ANY TIME. THIS WILL LEAD TO
MORE REQUIRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS IN THE FUTURE. IN TERMS
OF THE COMMITTEE'S QUESTION AND
HOW THESE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
CAN BE ADDRESSED YOU HAVE VERY
FUNDING INSTRUMENTS BUT YOU CAN
AUTHORIZED. DIRECT
APPROPRIATIONS ARE PREFERABLE
FOR SMALLER DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS THAT KEEP COMING UP AS
INFRASTRUCTURE AGES. FOR SEISMIC
RENOVATION IF DIRECT
APPROPRIATIONS OR GRANTS ARE NOT
AVAILABLE WE WHICH FAVOR AND NO
INTEREST REVOLVING LOAN FUND
DEDICATED. FOR THAT PURPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK I WILL WHAT'S
THE ROCK DRAKE A QUESTION FOR
YOU SEE WHAT'S THE ROUGH
BREAKDOWN OF YOUR- IN YOUR
CAPITALIST HERE. FIRST DID YOU
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE VERSES-
SEISMIC. WITH R. ONE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLAR REQUEST YEAH THAT
WOULD BE ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
MILLION IN DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND THEN THE OTHER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS- INCLUDES BOTH SEISMIC
AND CLASSROOM RENEWAL AND SOME
NEW ACADEMIC FACILITIES IS THIS
I'D MAKE IT RENEWED. I'M SORRY
GO AHEAD SIR. YES SO IT IS
SEISMIC- RENOVATIONS AND THEN WE
WOULD ALSO DO A COVER UP
REPAIRS. WITHIN THE BUILDING SO
WOULD TAKE CARE MULTIPLE
CATEGORIES AT THE SAME TIME. IS
THIS SIZE MAKE PRIMARILY UC
BERKELEY. NO EACH CAMPUS WOULD
RECEIVE SOME AMOUNT OF FUNDING
AS A PRIMARILY CAL. THE SEISMIC
LEST. NO ACTUALLY THERE'S OTHER
CAMPUSES ON THE SEISMIC LIST AND
IN DIVIDING THE ONE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS- BECAUSE WE DO
WANT TO OF DIRECT SOME OF THAT
TO CLASS REMARKABLE AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY EACH CAMPUS WOULD
RECEIVE SOME FUNDING. OKAY. YEAH
WELL WE HAVE THE OVERALL YOU
KNOW REQUEST IN THIS IS ALWAYS A
GOOD USE OF ONE TIME MONEY SO HE
CERTAINLY WILL SEE WHAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE. AFTER WE COME UP WITH
THE REVENUE PROJECTIONS AFTER
THE MAY REVISE AND WE'LL- GET
BACK. TO YOU ON THIS ISSUE SMALL
THIS ISSUE OPEN QUESTIONS WITH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. DR CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR. I OFTEN
WONDERED WHY NO UC SYSTEM- OR
ANY OF THE STATE AGENCIES- I DO
NOT PLAN ON. SETTING ASIDE A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF-
MAINTENANCE. COST RATHER THAN
USING UP- THE ENTIRE BUDGET AND
YOUR BUDGET AND ACCUMULATE THAT
BACKLOG OFF THE MAINTENANCE
PROBLEM ARE AND THAT YEARS
LATER- ASK FOR LUMP SUM TO CATCH
UP WITH THAT THE- ARE IN YOUR
DATA I SEE WHAT THE TWO POINT
NINE SOMETHING BILLION DOLLARS
OF BACKLOG GOT US- TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY. AND IF I WAS
STILL PRESIDENT- OR EVEN MY OWN
HOUSE- TO MAKE IT EASY I GOT I
HAVE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT SAVE IF I SOME NOW REPAIR
NEEDS TO BE DONE IF A ROOF WAYS-
LEAKING ARE GONNA SPEND- TONY
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ARE
GOING TO HAVE THAT KIND OF
QUESTION IS A HOME OR A CELL
COMMONSENSE. WHY ARE YOU SEE
SYSTEM YES AND NOT PRACTICING
THAT THE BASIC PRINCIPLE. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SIR. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY SPENDS OR IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE SPENT ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION ON CAMPUS
MAINTENANCE. SPENDING ONCAMPUS
MAINTENANCE IS A OF. RED CALLED
THE CAMPUS LEADERSHIP HAVE TO
MAKE. TWENTY MAINTAINING THE
FACILITIES I'M PROVIDING STUDENT
SERVICES AND INSTRUCTION SO
THOSE ARE THE COMPETING NEEDS ON
THE CAMPUS AND BECAUSE WE WANT
TO ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS HAVE
A GREAT EXPERIENCE AND WE HAVE
pSO MANY NEEDS THAT ARE EMERGING
WITHIN STUDENT COMMUNITY
CAMPUSES HAVE BEEN INVESTING IN
STUDENTS. THROUGH DIRECT
SERVICES AND INSTRUCTION- WHILE
WE DO RECEIVE FUNDING FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FROM THE
STATE OF BECAUSE OUR CAMPUSES
ARE NOW REACHING THAT POINT OF
AGING- WHERE MANY OF THE SYSTEMS
ARE STARTING TO FAIL OF THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS GROWING
FASTER THAN OUR ABILITY TO
ADDRESS IT. YEAH THE WORD THIS
OFFICE- DEFERRED MAINTENANCE OUT
THAT THIS- LATER IT'LL COST YOU
EVENTUALLY MORE BECAUSE TO IT
THAT THE PROBLEM OR PART OF
COMPOUND A RATHER THAN
MAINTAINING IT IS- AT THE LAST
BLAST SO COST OF SO. I WISH IS
TAMPA SO WHAT IT WOULD HAVE-
SUBGROUP BUDGET ASIDE IS SET
ASIDE AND- REGULARLY MAINTAINED
SO THAT THAT THERE WOULD BE NO
ISSUE OF FOUR SO CALLED THE BACK
ROW GOOD MENTORS SO PROBLEM SO
AND- EVENTUALLY COSTING- YOUR
INSTITUTION. OR EVEN- TAXPAYERS
MONEY. THAT'S A COMMON. THANK
YOU SIR. OKAY THANK YOU. YOU
KNOW THE QUESTIONS ON THIS
ISSUE- ISSUES NUMBER FOUR THESE
ARE THEM MISCELLANEOUS PROPOSALS
FROM THE JANUARY TEN BUDGET FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PLEASE
PROCEED. MORE INJECTS WILL
DEPARTMENT FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF OTHER EXCITING
PROPOSALS INCLUDING SIX MILLION
WHO ARE. I'M GOING GENERAL FUND
TO SUPPORT ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
FOR CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH WITH THE UC. TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ARE GOING GENERAL FUND
TO SUPPORT THE UC'S FIREARM
VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER. HI AND
A TEN MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO THE UC SAN
FRANCISCO DYSLEXIA CENTER FOR
RESEARCH- THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN FOSTER
YOUTH PROGRAMS WILL BE USED TO
PROVIDE COUNSELING. SERVICE
COORDINATION AND OTHER RELEVANT
STUDENTS SUPPORTS TO HELP
FOSTER- YOU TO COMPLETE COLLEGE-
THE AMBITIONS FOR FIREARM AND
SELECTS A RESEARCH. ALSO BUILT
ON SEVERAL YEARS OF SUCCESSFUL
INVESTMENTS. HE'S IN THE
RESOURCES WILL HELP BOTH CENTERS
INCREASE RESEARCH AND IN THE
CASE OF THE CSS DISLIKES IS THAT
OUR- FURTHER VALIDATE YOU
DEVELOPMENT OF AN EARLY
SCREENING TOOL- THANKS AND AGAIN
HAVE TO ASK QUESTIONS FONG
TRANSCRIPTION. THANK YOU. HERE
IS THE CALIFORNIA LOL. THAT
PROPOSED ISSUE FOR A WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH ONE OF THOSE
PROPOSALS WHICH IS AROUND
DYSLEXIA RESEARCH TO LOOK FOR A
FINAL FOCUS MY COMMENTS JUST ON
THAT PROPOSAL. NOW YOUR AGENDA
NOTES THE STATE PROVIDED ONE
TIME FUNDING TO THE UC SAN
FRANCISCO DYSLEXIA CENTER IN
PAST YEARS AND AT ONE TIME
FUNDING. IS INTENDED TO HELP
DEVELOP A NEW SCHOOL A SCREENING
TOOL. THAT HELPS FLAG EARLY AND
EARLY SIGNS OF LEARNING
CHALLENGES BUT THAT WITH THAT
AND I'LL SUPPORT EARLY
INTERVENTIONS AND POTENTIALLY
pPREVENT STUDENTS FROM. LACED
INTO US EDUCATION. OVERARCHING
OBJECTIVES OF THAT PROPOSAL SHE
REACHED HER REASONABLE TO US WE
HAVE TWO CONCERNS THE FIRST IS
THAT THE PROPOSAL TO DATE HAS
VERY LITTLE STATUTORY GUIDANCE
FOR REPORTING AROUND IT BUDGET
DEFEATED MINISTRATION HAS REALLY
DEFINED THE SCOPE AND OBJECTIVES
OF THE DYSLEXIA CENTER RATHER
THAN THE LGISLATURE AND THERE'S
BEEN VERY LITTLE REPORTING ABOUT
. AND THEN SECONDLY THE
LEGISLATURE OTHER ADMINISTRATION
HAS NOT PROVIDED THE LEGISLATURE
THE LONG TERM. IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN SO THE LEGISLATURE HAS
LITTLE INFORMATION AS TO HOW THE
PROJECT TO BE SCALED STATEWIDE.
DURING THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUES TO SUPPORT
FUNDING- WE RECOMMEND ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES BY ADOPTING MORE
STATUTORY GUIDANCE. AND ALSO
ADOPTING REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
THANK. THANK YOU YOU SEE. THANK
YOU I WILL REVIEW THE PROPOSALS
AND THE ORDER THAT THEY APPEAR
IN YOUR AGENDA. FOR FOSTER YOUTH
PROGRAMS RECOGNIZING THE UNIQUE
OBSTACLES FACED BY FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
INCLUDES SIX MILLION AN ONGOING.
FUNDS FOR STUDENT SERVICES AND
ACADEMIC ADVISING SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTED A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
THESE STUDENTS HAVE ALREADY
OVERCOME TREMENDOUS OBSTACLES IN
PURSUING THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS
pSIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES WHEN THEY
MAKE PROGRESS TOWARDS
GRADUATION. THIS ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT WILL ASSIST THEM ON THE
PATH TO SUCCESSFUL GRADUATION
CURRENTLY UC CAMPUSES HAVE
FOSTER YOU SERVICES PAID FOR
WITH DONATIONS AND GRANTS. THE
CAMPUSES HAVE NOT ESTABLISHED
DEDICATED FOSTER YOUTH SERVICES
WITH STATE GENERAL FUND SUPPORT.
THIS PROPOSED ONGOING STATE
FUNDING WILL ENSURE THE CAMPUS
AGAIN HIRE PERMANENT
PROFESSIONAL STAFF RATHER THAN
RELYING ON TEMPORARY CONTRACTS.
OR APPROACH TO YOUTH ARE TWO AND
A HALF MORE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS THAN
OTHER STUDENTS AND MORE LIKELY
TO REPORT FOOD INSECURITY.
ADDITIONAL ACADEMIC ADVISING AND
SUPPORT SERVICES WOULD HELP THE
STUDENTS GET ACCESS THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO GRADUATE
AND THRIVE WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED SIX MILLION. MOVING ON
THE FIREARMS RESEARCH FIREARMS
ARE HEALTH CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA.
BETWEEN NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND
TWO AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN ONE
CALIFORNIANS DIED EVERY THREE
HOURS FROM GUN VIOLENCE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN ACCORDING TO THE
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL
200-090-0405 PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA DIED FROM GUNSHOT
WOUNDS. FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN MEN
BETWEEN THE AGES OF FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY FIVE GUNSHOT WOUNDS. ARE
A LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH.
REDRESS THIS PUBLIC CRISIS THE
LEGISLATURE CODIFY TO MAKE OF
THE U. OF. FIREARM RESEARCH
CENTER AT UC DAVIS AS AN
ACADEMIC AND POLICY RESEARCH
CENTER THE CENTER FOR AREAS OF
ACTIVITY INCLUDE RESEARCH
ASSISTANTS TO POLICY MAKERS
TRAINING AND EDUCATION FOR
RESEARCHERS PRACTITIONERS AND
THE PUBLIC. AND MEDICAL HEALTH
PROVIDER EDUCATION AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND ARE NOT OPTIONAL
GRANT PROGRAMS TO FACILITATE
RESEARCH BY OTHERS. THE CENTERS
WILL APPOINT PROJECTS HAS
DEVELOPED A CURRICULUM TO TEACH
MEN MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS ABOUT FIREARM INJURY
PREVENTION. THE CENTER IS NOW
DISSEMINATING THIS CURRICULUM
AND EVALUATING ITS
EFFECTIVENESS. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE TWO MILLION PROPOSED TO
CONTINUE THIS CRITICAL WORK. I'M
DYSLEXIC CENTER. THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES TEN MILLION FOR THE
UCSF DYSLEXIA CENTER CONDUCT
TRANSLATIONAL RESEARCH AND BUILD
UP THE CAPACITYOF SCIENCE TO
DEVELOP ASSESSMENT AND
INTERVENTION PRACTICES FOR
CHILDREN WITH DYSLEXIA. THE
CENTER IS DEVELOPING A TOOL
CALLED MULTITUDE STAFF WILL
PROVIDE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY INCLUSIVE SCIENCE
BASED ASSESSMENT OF YOUNG
CHILDREN WITH DYSLEXIA. HAS
PRACTICES HAVE TESTED CHILDREN
IN THIRD GRADE OR LATER ONLY
AFTER THEY DEVELOP NOTICEABLE
LEARNING DIFFICULTIES AND THEN
ONLY IN ENGLISH. AT THIS POINT
MANY CHILDREN WITH DYSLEXIA HAVE
ALREADY FALLEN BEHIND IN
LEARNING AND MUST ENTER SPECIAL
INSTRUCTION CLASSROOM. THE
MULTITUDES PROJECT WILL PROVIDE
A DIGITAL PLATFORM TOOL THAT
TEACHERS CAN OPERATE WITHOUT A
SPECIALIST PRESENT THE SCREENING
WILL TAKE TWENTY MINUTES FOR THE
SECOND TWENTY MINUTES SCREENING
FOR CHILDREN WHO STRUGGLE WITH
THE FIRST STEP. THE SYSTEM
SCREENS KINDERGARTEN AND FIRST
GRADE STUDENTS TO IDENTIFY
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF RISK FOR
LEARNING CHALLENGES BEFORE THE
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE FAILURE.
SCHOOLS CAN BEGIN EARLY
INTERVENTION BEFORE THE CHILD
FALLS BEHIND OR HAS TO BE PLACED
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT. FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FUNDING. VERY QUICKLY I
WOULD LIKE TO READ YOUR SUPPORT
UC REGENTS BUDGET REQUEST NOT
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. FIRST OF THESE IS THE
STUDENT ACADEMIC PREPARATION AND
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERSHIPS ARE
SAFE BUT PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
A THROUGH G. COURSES THE
STUDENTS FROM HIGH SCHOOLS DO
NOT OFFER A SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF
THOSE COURSES. IN ADDITION AP
COURSES SUMMER ACADEMIC
PREPARATION AND MENTORING OUR
OFFER TO ENCOURAGE HIGH SCHOOL
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
TO ATTEND A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY. WE ARE REQUESTING AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION ON GOING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS. AT A TIME OF
SIGNIFICANT LEARNING IMPACTS FOR
LOW INCOME DISTRICTS THESE FUNDS
ARE NEEDED TO ENSURE THE
PANDEMIC GENERATION DOES NOT
LOSE OUT ON HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND SECOND WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SIX MILLION
FOR HER FOSTER YOUTH SERVICES.
AND REQUEST YOUR ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR OTHER VULNERABLE
STUDENTS FIVE MILLION FOUR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND FOUR
MILLION FOUR IN CARCERAL SYSTEM
IMPACTED STUDENTS. THIS FUNDING
WOULD ALLOW CAMPUS IS TO
ESTABLISH DEDICATED PROGRAMS FOR
ADVISING AND SUPPORT FOR THE
STUDENTS. AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
FOR MILLION ON GOING FOR THE UC
CANCER CONSORTIUM FOR UNIFIED
STRATEGY TO LEVERAGE THE
EXPERTISE STRENGTH AND SCALE OF
THE UC SYSTEM TO IMPROVE CANCER
CARE AND PATIENT ACCESS. A
BETTER STORE OF THE DIVERSE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA THE
CANCER CENTER WOULD PROVIDE A
CURRENT CANCER DATABASE FOR
PRECISION ONCOLOGY. PUBLISHED
CLINICAL TRIALS GREAT TEAMS OF
DISEASE SPECIFIC CHALLENGES AND
OFFER SECOND OPINIONS. TO
PATIENTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ON THESE PROPOSALS. SEEING NONE
I DO NOT HAVE ANY AS WELL-
SEVERAL OF THESE ARE ISSUES THAT
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THE PAST
FEW YEARS- SO WE WILL HOLD THESE
ISSUES OPENED. AND PROCEED WITH
THE NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. CLIMATE
CHANGE PROPOSALS. GOOD MORNING
GENTLE BERMAN THANKS ARE
EXPIRATION IS COMMITTED TO
ADVANCING SOLUTIONS TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. OUR BUDGET SEEKS TO
LEVERAGE THE EXPERTISE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
TO FURTHER THOSE AFTER. THESE
INVESTMENTS INCLUDE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT RESEARCH A
MEDICATION WORK- NOTABLY
TRANSLATIONAL RESEARCH PROGRAMS
THAT WILL CYSTIC KNOWLEDGE
TRANSFER FROM THE ACADEMIC BROWN
TO THE PRACTICAL. FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT CLIMATE TECHNOLOGY
INCUBATORS ON ITS CAMPUSES. I
WHICH COMPLEMENTS PREVIOUS
INNOVATION HUB INVESTMENTS AT
THE UC. AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND. FOR
CLIMATE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND TRAINING AT THE UNIVERSITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU L. A. O.
PLEASE. SO THIS ISSUE HAS THREE
PROPOSALS WITHIN IT ONE FOCUSED
ON CLIMATE CHANGE RESEARCH ONE
FOCUSED ON OUR CLIMATE
TECHNOLOGY INCUBATORS AND ONE
FOCUSED ON WORKFORCE ISSUES.
GENERALLY FOR ALL THREE
PROPOSALS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
VERY LITTLE INFORMATION. OTHER
PROPOSALS COME WITH JUST A FEW
LINES OF PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE.
THIS IS A FEW LINES DO NOT
PROVIDE CLEAR GOALS ESTABLISH
PARAMETERS A RELEASE OF THE
FUNDS OR ESTABLISH ANY REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. TWENTY
MINISTRATION- SOME PROPOSALS
LIKE THIS TO THE LEGISLATURE IT
PUTS PRESSURE ON THE LEGISLATURE
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES
BY PROVIDING MORE STATUTORY
GOALS ESTABLISHING BETTER
PARAMETERS. ESTABLISHING
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. THE
EFFORTS TAKE TIME AWAY FROM THE
LEGISLATURE FROM OTHER
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO A PART
PART OF THE BUDGET. WE THINK OF
THE LEGISLATURE REVIEWS THESE
PROPOSALS- THERE ARE AREAS YOU
COULD- PRIORITIZED OVER OTHERS.
FOR EXAMPLE WE THINK OF THE
THREE PROPOSALS CLIMATE CHANGE
RESEARCH- COULD BE THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY AMONG THESE PROPOSALS.
WE THINK CLIMATE CHANGE RESEARCH
IS AN ACTIVITY THAT COULD HELP-
STATED IT'S CLIMATE CHANGE
MITIGATION GOALS. AND ALSO IT'S
JUST COMMUNITIES AND THEIR
ADAPTATION EFFORTS. IN ORDER TO
RETHINK THE LEGISLATURE EVER
WERE INTERESTED IN PURSUING-
THIS IS A PROPOSAL IT COULD
ADOPT- MORE STATUTORY GUIDANCE
STOP WISHING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. IN ADDITION THAT A
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD NOT REQUIRE
YOU SEE TO. COORDINATE THE
STATE'S VERY AS ENVIRONMENTAL
AND NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCIES
WHEN DEVELOPING THE RESEARCH
AGENDA. WE THINK BECAUSE OF THAT
THE LEGISLATURE. YEAH HOW MUCH
CONFIDENCE AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
YOU TEASE EFFORTS WOULD ALIGN
WITH EXISTING STATE EFFORTS
WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE PURSUE- OPTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT ANY RESEARCH FUNDING
AS WELL COORDINATED AMONG THE
STATE'S VARIOUS INTERNAL
PROTECTION NATURAL RESURGENT
RESOURCE ENTITIES. I'M THE
SECONDARY EVERYTHING THE LEAD
CONVENTION TO WOULD BE. QUITE AN
AUDIENCE. OKAY WHERE THAT HAVE
SOME. TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
COMMUTER IN THE FORMATION NEW
BUSINESS THAT DEVELOP NEW
TECHNOLOGY. THE PROPOSAL LACKS A
LOT OF BASIC DETAILS THAT WOULD
HELP THE LEGISLATURE UNDERSTAND
ITS IMPACT. ON THE CITY
CURRENTLY HAS MANY- COLLAGEN
COMPETITORS INCLUDING A FEW THAT
FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON CLIMATE
CHANGE ISSUES. AT HAND THE
PROPOSAL DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO REALLY ASSESS HOW
THE TO KEEP READERS WOULD ALIGN
AND COORDINATE. WITH THESE
EXISTING INCUBATORS. THIS IS AN
AREA WE THINK THE- WORK IN IN
PER MARC BY CHANGING. THE DIRECT
THE ADMINISTRATION TO COME BACK
AND PROVIDE- MORE INFORMATION
FOR SALES. AND IN THE FINAL AREA
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
THEN TURN TO WOULD BE WORKFORCE
ISSUES. THIS IS AN AREA WE THINK
WOULD BE THE LOWEST PRIORITY AS
THE- STATE ALREADY PROVIDES
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR ONGOING
WORKFORCE PROPOSALS. THE STATE
ALREADY PROVIDES ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR VARIOUS WORKFORCE
INITIATIVES ADOPTED LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. SOME OF WHICH APPEAR TO
SHARE SOME SIMILAR GOALS TO THE
UC PROPOSAL THE REASON WE THINK
THE LEGISLATURE COULD REJECT
THIS PROPOSAL WITHOUT
NECESSARILY PROVIDING MUCH MORE
CONSERVATIVE GIVEN THE EXISTING
LEVEL OF ACTIVITY ALREADY GOING
ON THE STREET. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU YOU SEE. THANK YOU CLIMATE
CHANGE IS A CRISIS IMPACTING THE
LIVES OF ALL CALIFORNIANS WHILE
THE STATE LEADERSHIP HAVE TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TOWARD
MITIGATION OF CLIMATE CHANGE IT
IS CLEAR THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO MITIGATE AND ADAPT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL COMMITS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
RESOURCES EXPERTISE
INFRASTRUCTURE NETWORKS AND
PARTNERSHIPS TO ADDRESS THE
STATE'S NEEDS AND ACCELERATE THE
STATE'S PROGRESS TOWARDS A
CLIMATE RESILIENCY GOALS THE
PURPOSE OF THE THREE PROGRAMS IS
TO GENERATE IDEAS PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES AS WELL AS A TRAINED
WORKFORCE TO HELP CALIFORNIANS
BECOME MORE RESILIENT THE
CHANGING CLIMATE. ORDER PROPOSES
A AMBITIOUS PLAN OR INNOVATIVE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RESEARCH FOR CLIMATE ADOPTION
STRATEGIES THE PROPOSED ONE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR RESEARCH
WOULD BE PROVIDED FOR CUTTING
EDGE TRANSLATIONAL SCIENCE.
THESE GRANTS WILL BE UNIQUE IN
FINDING INNOVATIVE CONCEPT WORK
NOT BUT THROUGH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES OR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THE OBJECTIVE WILL
BE TO SEEK NEW KNOWLEDGE THAT
HAS NOT BEEN PREVIOUSLY
EXPLORED. REGIONAL INNOVATION
INCUBATORS WILL BE AWARDED BASED
ON CONSIDERATIONS O EQUITY
REGIONAL CONTEXT LOCAL TRIBAL
AND COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AS
WELL AS THE ABILITY TO LEVERAGE
OUTSIDE INVESTMENTS AND
RESOURCES. INNOVATION
INVESTMENTS ARE CONCEIVED TO
COVER A RANGE OF FIELDS AND
ACTIVITIES SPENDING AGRICULTURE
AND HEALTH TRAINING LAB AND
MAKERSPACE ACTIVITIES MULTI
DISCIPLINARY NETWORKS OF
INCUBATION AND LAB FACILITIES.
COMBINED INCUBATOR ACCELERATOR
AND CO WORKING SPACES THEY WILL
BE OPEN TO INNOVATORS INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE OF THE UNIVERSITIES WITH
BROAD PARTICIPATION AND
ENGAGEMENT FROM INDUSTRY AND THE
PUBLIC SECTOR. THE REGIONAL WORK
FORCE. ARE INTENDED PRIMARILY TO
SERVE UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
STUDENTS FROM ACROSS THE STATE
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS
AS WELL AS ALUMNI WHO CAN
PARTICIPATE IN ON THE JOB
TRAINING FOR HUB FUNDED
ACTIVITIES. CAREER CERTIFICATION
AND TRAINING FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT YEAH YOU SEE
EXTENSION AND ON THE JOB
TRAINING AT THE INNOVATION HUBS
WILL PROVIDE THE TOOLS RESOURCES
AND SUPPORT TO PREPARE
CANDIDATES FOR A RANGE OF
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES. THESE SERVICES
ARE PRIMARILY DIRECTED AT
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO ENHANCE
AN EXISTING BACHELOR'S DEGREE OR
OTHERWISE ENHANCE THEIR.
EDUCATION WITH CERT TRAINING.
THE OVERALL OBJECT OF THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCE FUNDING OUR
CONTRIBUTE TO HELP BY A BY
PREDICT. AND JUST AND EQUITABLE
COMMUNITIES WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. PASSING NINE AGAIN THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT WE CERTAINLY
ARE WELL AWARE WE SUPPORTED
INCREASES FOR YOU SEE CLIMATE
CHANGE RESEARCH IN THE PRIOR
YEARS AND- WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO AGAIN THIS YEAR. WE WILL HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN- FINALISTS TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT.
UNIVERSITIES ARE THANK YOU SIR
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT BUDGET
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AS ONE BILLION DOLLARS OF THIS
AMOUNT SIX HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
MILLION OR 69% ARE PASSED
THROUGH OR FEEFOR SERVICE
FUNDING AN EXAMPLE OF THESE
KINDS OF FUNDS ARE THE BREAST
CANCER RESEARCH FUNDS UC
RECIEVESTHROUGH PROPOSITION
FUNDING. THE UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT RECEIVES TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE POINT ONE MILLION
IN UNRESTRICTED FUNDING. THESE
FUNDS ARE USED FOR SYSTEM WIDE
OF COURSE SERVICES PROGRAMS AND
INITIATIVES AND STRATEGIC
PRIORITIES. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT BUDGET IS DIVIDED INTO
THREE PARTS YOU SEE OKEY BUDGET
YOU SEE PATH BUDGET AND THE UC
AGRICULTURAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCES OR YOU SEE A IN OUR
BUDGET. THE BUDGET ACTOF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE **** THE FUNDING
METHODOLOGY FOR USE YOUR P. AND
YOU SEE PASSED. THROUGH THE
STATE OF CAMPUS ASSESSMENT THAT
WAS USED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
BEFORE THE UC OP A LINE ITEM.
THE STATE HAS DECIDED TO RETAIN
YOU SEE A AND R. AS ITS OWN LINE
ITEM AND ENHANCE THE STATE WHAT
SERVICES THAT YOU SEE A AND R.
PROVIDES WITH ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDING INVESTMENTS. TODAY I'M
GOING TO FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON
THE U. C. O. P. BUDGET. HAVING
RETURNED TO CAMPUS ASSESSMENT
NOT ONLY IS THE TOTAL USE YOUR
BE BUDGET FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO WITH THE SAME AS IT
WAS FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY.
BUT FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
THE REGION'S APPROVAL OF THE
TOTAL CAMPUS ASSESSMENT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION WHICH IS THE SAME
AMOUNT. AS THE STATE LINE ITEM
FOR YOU C. O. P. WAS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. YOU STILL BE
BUDGET TODAY'S NOT THE UC A PRE
BUDGET OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
IMPORTANT CHANGES TO
TRANSPARENCY DOCUMENTATION AND
DECISION MAKING HAVE BEEN MADE.
THESE REFORMS INCLUDE THE
FORMATION OF THE EXECUTIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE COMPOSED OF
CHANCELLORS VICE CHANCELLORS OF
FINANCE AND OTHER CAMPUS
LEADERS. WILL REVIEW THE UC O.
P. EXPENDITURES AND PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UC WOULD BE PROGRAMS AND
EXPENDITURES. IN ADDITION YOU
SEE OP HAS DEVELOPED AND
DOCUMENTED A RESERVE POLICY. AND
RESEARCH ARE NOT REPORTED
REGULARLY FOR THE UC REGENTS
ALONG WITH BUDGET AMOUNTS TO
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES. UTILITY
IMPLEMENTED AN ENTIRELY NEW
BUDGET AND PLANNING SYSTEM. AND
COMPLETED A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW
OF EACH YEAR C. O. P. FUND AND
ITS USE. THERE WAS ALSO AN
EXTENSIVE PROCESS TO DOCUMENT
EACH PROGRAM AN INITIATIVE I'M
PROVIDE CLEAR DEFINITIONS OF
EACH. UC CHANCELLORS REQUESTED
TO RETURN TO THE CAMPUS
ASSESSMENT AND THEY DECIDE WHAT
THEY'RE CAMPUS WHICH FUNDING
SOURCES THEY WILL USED TO PAY
THE ASSESSMENT. THE CAMPUS WILL
REPORT ON THE FUNDING SOURCES
THEY USED FOR THE ASSESSMENT
AFTER. THE FISCAL YEAR BOOKS ARE
CLOSED. HE SEE REGION'S WILL
APPROVE THE PLAN TWENTY TO THE
TWENTY. YOU SEE OKAY BUDGET IN
MAY. YOU SEE REGION'S WILL
APPROACH A FINAL YOU SEE KEYPAD
IN JULY. THAT WILL REFLECT ANY
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS ON THE UC
BUDGET. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA REQUEST THAT YOU
ALLOW THE CONTINUATION OF THE
CAMPUS ASSESSMENT UPON THE UC
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT AND YOU
SEE PATH OPERATIONS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU
AT QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON THIS ITEM. I DO NOT
HAVE ANY WILL HOLD THE SERVICE
YES MISTER DOCTOR CHOI CHU THANK
YOU- I WONDER. IF FOR A USE O.
P. FAR OF SELF EXAMINATION OF-
HOW YOUR EACH YEAR AS A BUDGET
IS- EFFICIENTLY USED. AND HOW
YOU CAN. SAVE MONEY- IT IS SO
EASY TO ASK. ANNUAL BUDGET THE
TYPICALLY INCREASE THE BUDGET
FOR YOUR OPERATION AND THE
SYSTEM WIDE THE NEEDS- BUT THE
ONCE YOU GET THE FUNDING- I
WONDER. WHETHER THERE'S ANY IS
SELF EXAMINATION AKA SEVERAL
AUDITING- BEFORE STATE DOES-
THAT CAN WORK ON A TEAM-
EXPENDITURES SO OF ALL- YOU SEE
OR PIECE OF BUDGET. I AM NOW
pAN AFFLUENT CAN YOU ANSWER THAT
. THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO IN TERMS OF
EVALUATION OF THE U. C. O. P.
EXPENDITURES THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE NOW ABOUT MEETS
MONTHLY AND THEN SOME MONTHS-
TWICE A MONTH TO GO THROUGH THE
UC OF P. EXPENDITURES AND SEE IF
THEY ALIGN WITH CAMPUS
PRIORITIES- THE COMMITTEE
INCLUDES CHANCELLORS OF CAMPUSES
WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING
THE ASSESSMENT. AND DECIDING IF
THEY WANT TO FUND THOSE SERVICES
THAT THEY ARE RECEIVING THE UC
REGENTS NOW ARE ALSO REGULARLY
BRIEFED UP ON Q. C. O. P.
ACTIVITIES AND EXPENDITURES- AND
ALSO COMPARISON OF BUDGET TO
ACTUALS SO THIS IS NEW
ACTIVITIES SENSE OF THAT WORD
OUT OF PLACE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. THAT HAVE BEEN PUT IN
PLACE IN ORDER TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT THE UC OP BUDGET REFLECTS
THE NEEDS OF THE CAMPUSES AND
ONLY SPENDS MONEY ON THOSE
SERVICES THAT ARE VALUABLE TO
CAMPUSES THAT SAVED. UP FUNDING
SYSTEM WIDE. CAN WE CAN. I THINK
THIS IS A VERY VERY IMPORTANT A
FUNCTION THAT THE U. S. C. O. P.
S. WHEN YOU ALLOCATE THOUGH- AND
YOUR BUDGET SO TO EACH OF WHAT
THAT NINE CAMPUSES THANK
CAMPUSES SHOWS- I. LOST A NUMBER
OF ALL UC SYSTEM IS A CAMPUS TEN
CAMPUSES NOW HOW THEY ARE-
EFFICIENTLY- THAT THE FUNDING
ALLOCATED FUNDING HAS BEEN USED
TO AND THE FOR THE PURPOSE- OF-
INITIAL BUDGET REQUEST SO I
THINK THAT US- YOU SEE OP'S. JOB
WITH. THANK YOU SIR- IT DID TO
THE- BY THEIR- COMMITTEE AND
EVERY CHANCE THEY UC REGENTS
HAVE AN INTERNAL AUDITING TEAM
THAT FOUGHT ITS U. C. O. P.
EXPENDITURES. AND THE REASON DOT
AUDIT TEAM IS LOCATED AT THE
REGION'S IS THAT SO THAT THEY
WOULD BE INDEPENDENT FROM- THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
LEADERSHIP AND ANY CAMPUS
LEADERSHIP. BUT WE DO HAVE THAT
INTERNAL AUDIT TEAM WHO- EXAMINE
DO YOU C. O. P. EXPENDITURES AS
WELL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RHYS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A TWO
PART QUESTION HOW DOES THE UC
DETERMINE HOW MUCH EACH CAMPUS
IS ASSESSED AND AS THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT CONSIDERING
INCREASING CAMPUS ASSESSMENT IN. TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SO THE
CAMPUS ASSESSMENT IS BASED ON A
FORMULA THAT LOOKS AT THE-
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES FACULTY AND
STUDENTS AT EACH CAMPUS- AS WELL
AS THE TOTAL CAMPUS
EXPENDITURES. UP TO LOOK AT WHAT
THE AMOUNT OF THE ASSESSMENT
SHOULD BE THE ASSESSMENT MUST BE
APPROVED BY THE REGENTS BEFORE
IT CAN BE IMPLEMENTED- AND IN
TERMS OF A POTENTIAL INCREASE
FOR NEXT YEAR. YOU C. O. P- IS
PROPOSED WELL PROPOSED TO THE
REGENTS IN MAY A NEW BUDGET- AND
WE ARE LOOKING AT INCLUDING
EIGHT OF THREE PERCENT- STAFF
SALARY INCREASE WITHIN THAT BUT
THAT HAS NOT AT THIS POINT BEEN
APPROVED BY THE REGENTS. THE UC
REGENTS MUST APPROVE THE
ASSESSMENT LEVEL BEFORE IT CAN
BE PASSED ON TO THE CAMPUSES.
THANK YOU END OF MY LAST
QUESTION IS HOW'S YOU SEE
COMPLETED ALL OF THE STATE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS. THERE
ARE SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
THE AUDITOR THINGS ARE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA JUST
CONTINUE TO WORK ON- WE HAVE
COMPLETED THE SALARY ASSESSMENT
AND RETAINED AN INDEPENDENT.
EVALUATOR TO ASSIST US WITH THAT
OR- EVEN DEPENDENT EVALUATOR TO
ASSIST US WITH THAT- TO ENSURE
THAT YOU SEE OKAY SALARIES WERE
ALIGNED WITH THE MARKET- AND
ALSO THE AUDITOR WOULD. LIKE THE
UC REGENTS TO APPROVE AN ANNUAL
BUDGET FOR YOU C. O. P. EARLIER
IN THE YEAR OF WE ARE STILL
DOING A PRELIMINARY BUDGET- FOR
UC SYSTEM AS A WHOLE IN
NOVEMBER. AND EIGHT YOU SEE OKAY
BUDGET PRIMARILY IN MAY BECAUSE
AT THAT POINT WE DO NOT YET KNOW
WHAT THE- FUNDING LEVELS AND
PROGRAM LEVELS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVES WILL BE SO
WE ARE STILL NOT APPROVING A
FINAL BUDGET UNTIL AFTER THE
LEGISLATURE PASSES THE BUDGET
FOR THE STATE. IT JUST AS A
FOLLOW UP WHEN WOULD YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT THE STATE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS. OUT
WOULD BE COMPLETED. WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR- IN REGARDS TO
THE- STAFF MEETINGS STAFF SALARY
LEVELS WE CONTINUE TO EXAMINE
THOSE. UP AND THEN DISSIPATE
THAT THERE WILL BE FUTURE LOOK
AT MAKING SURE THAT THE SALARY
LEVELS FOR STAFF ARE ALIGNED
WITH OTHER STATE AGENCIES ON THE
MARKET- IN TERMS OF THE-
APPROVAL OF THESE. UC OKAY
BUDGET- WE DO HAVE A PRELIMINARY
APPROVAL BEFORE THE FISCAL YEAR
BEGINS- BUT BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE AND WILL
DOES MAKE CHANGES TO THE UC
BUDGET. OF AROUND THE JUNE
FIFTEENTH STATE BUDGET ACT BEING
PASSED. WE CAN'T REALLY PASS THE
FINAL BUDGET. BUT SYSTEM MORE
FOR YOU SEE OP BEFORE THAT TIME
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO BE RESPONSIVE
TO THE LEGISLATIVE CHANGES THAT
ARE BEING MADE. IF I MAY MY LAST
QUESTION MR. YOU MENTIONED THAT
YOU HAD THERE'S TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE MILLION
UNRESTRICTED FOR THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT. MY QUESTION IS
WHAT PRACTICES ARE IN PLACE TO
ENSURE. THAT THE UC OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT'S BUDGET REMAINS
TRANSPARENT. AND THAT IT DOESN'T
GROW SIGNIFICANTLY THERE WAS AN
ISSUE. TWO YEARS AGO THREE YEARS
AGO- ESPECIALLY WITHOUT THE
INPUT OF THE REGION SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SO THE BUDGET GROWTH
WAS ACTUALLY AN ISSUE PRIOR TO
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT CAME OUT IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SINCE THAT TIME YOU C.
O. P. REPORTS REGULARLY TO THE
REGENTS AND AN EXTENSIVE OF
BUDGET. THAT COMPARES- THE- OR
PUBLISHED YET TO ACTUAL
EXPENDITURES I'M PROVIDES ANY
FUNDS THAT ARE STILL REMAINING
AS WELL OF RESERVES WE ARE
UTILIZING. THE DISPLAYED AS
RECOMMENDED- OR FORM OF THE
DISPLAY AS RECOMMENDED BY THE
STATE AUDITOR FOR HOW TO BEST
DISPLAY BUDGET INFORMATION TO
THE REGENTS SO THAT IS ONE
REFORM THAT HAS BEEN DONE- TO
INCREASE THE TRANSPARENCY IN
ADDITION THERE NOW IS THE
EXECUTIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE THAT
MEETS. OUR COMPOSED OF
CHANCELLORS AND VICE CHANCELLORS
OF BUDGET AND OTHER LEADERSHIP
WHO DISCUSS WHETHER OR NOT THE
U. C. O. P. FUNCTIONS MEET-
CAMPUS EXPECTATIONS FOR SERVICES
AND IF THEY ARE ALIGNED WITH
WHAT THE CAMPUS IS NEEDED FROM
YOU C. O. P. THAT GROUP ALSO
MAKES RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE-
APPROPRIATE FUNDED LEVEL FOR
EACH OF THOSE SERVICES. OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE PASSED TO
THE PRESIDENT AND TO THE
REGION'S AND ULTIMATELY IT IS
THE UC REGENTS WHO HAVE TO
APPROVE THE UC OP BUDGET YOU SEE
OKAY CANNOT ALTER DOC BUDGET.
WITHOUT WE GENTLE APPROVAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER. OKAY
THANK YOU GOOD QUESTIONS. THE
END WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN
NEXT ITEM THE FINAL ITEM IS THE
TASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW. WE HAVE
THE HASTINGS REPRESENTATIVES
HERE. BERMAN A FINANCE WILL
BEGIN EN LA OF IT HE STICKS.
ZACKS WITH BERMAN FINANCE- THANK
YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS MORNING TO
DISCUSS UC HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
THE LAWS BUDGET- AT UC HASTINGS
IS AFFILIATED WITH THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SYSTEM-
BUT IS GOVERNED BY ITS OWN BOARD
OF DIRECTORS. LOCATED IN SAN
FRANCISCO IT PRIMARILY SERVES
STUDENTS SEEKING A JURIS DOCTOR
DEGREE BUT ALSO HAS A MASTER OF
LAWS PROGRAM A MASTER'S STUDIES
IN LAW PROGRAM AND A MASTER OF
SCIENCE HEALTH BALLS IN LAW
PROGRAM. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE I
EXCUSE ME INTO MAY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE I UC HASTINGS EMERALD- NINE
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS. I DON'T
TUITION FOR FEES AND FEES FOR
ITS JURIS DOCTOR PROGRAM IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE I
WILL. BE FORTY SIX THOUSAND
THIRTY THREE DOLLARS. THE BUDGET
PROVIDES IT TO MILLION DOLLAR ON
GENERAL FUND. TO SUPPORT- I'VE
PATIENTS EXHIBITS FOR OPERATIONS
BRINGING ITS TOTAL GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION IN THE BUDGET YEAR
AT TWO TWENTY ONE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU L. A. O. HOUSTON CONCENTRA
SALLY- COMPARED TO THE UC BUDGET
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
LEGISLATURE IN A BETTER POSITION
TO REVIEW HASTINGS BUDGET
PROPOSAL THERE ARE TWO REASONS
FOR THIS. ONE IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BASED
INCREASE IS CONNECTED TO A
BUDGET PLAN THAT HASTINGS
DEVELOPED. BUDGET PLAN INCLUDES
SIR BASIC WORKLOAD INCREASES
LIKE SALARY INCREASES BENEFIT
COST INCREASES THINGS ALSO PLANS
TO HIRE US ADDITIONAL EMPLOYEES
AND REPLACE SOME RICH BY PLAY
REQUIREMENTS. AND THEN IN
ADDITION HASTINGS ANNUALLY
PROVIDES A LEGISLATURE A MULTI
YEAR PLAN THAT GIVES A
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATURE SENSE AS
TO WHERE IT'S HEADING. THE
NATIONAL AND IT'S NOT A CONTRACT
SO IT'S NOT SOMETHING
LEGISLATURE IS BEING ASKED TO
COMMIT TO TODAY. I'M SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- PROVIDES A
REASONABLE STARTING POINT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IN
TERMS OF FUNDING FOR HASTINGS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. IT IS A
STARTING POINT SO WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REVIEW HASTINGS PLANS FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR INSURANCE PLANS
ALIGNED WITH ITS PRIORITIES. ONE
OTHER POINT YOU JUST WANT TO
QUICKLY EMPHASIZED TWO THINGS-
IS CURRENTLY UNDERTAKING AN
INITIATIVE TO CHANGE ITS NAME.
THEN INTENT ALTERNATELY REQUIRES
OF A BILL FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
ANY CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
OFFICE HASTINGS NOTED THAT THAT
NAME CHANGE COULD BE ASSOCIATED
WITH SOME ONE TIME COSTS SUCH AS
CHANGING BUILDING NAMES THOSE
COSTS ARE NOT. INCLUDED IN
HASTINGS EXPENDITURE PLAN THAT
IT SUBMITTED AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO THAT WOULD
BE SOMETHING TO KEEP AN EYE OUT
FOR EITHER THE REVISION. IN THE
FUTURE BUDGET CYCLE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
LAW. I THANK YOU ARE THE RUN SAM
HARDY AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
DAVID HEY MAN- THE DEAN OF THE
LAW SCHOOL AND I'M SORRY IF I
GAVE THE SERVER THE COLLEGE'S
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER I'M
GIPSON GRATEFUL- AND THANKFUL
FOR THE LEGISLATORS. SUPPORT OF. PATIENTS OUT OF THE LAW. THE
PROPOSAL BUDGET. IT WAS STRONG
AND GROWING WITH THE WAY FOR IN
TERMS OF PER AND- IN AN X. CLASS
PAST FALL FROM AND- FACT. I
THINK WAS JUST UNDER HUNDRED
WITH HALF AGAIN STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND 56% WOMEN. INSTEAD OF
TALKING STUDENT POPULATION TO
DEFEND ELEVEN FOR THE COMING.
OUR MARKET AND IT'S KICKING TO
BE GOOD THE CLASS OF TWENTY
POINT ONE HAS EVEN PER THREE.
WITHIN THE FIRST TIME PASSWORD
OF 80% WE HAVEN'T GOT IT CAN YOU
YEAH DESPERATE TOPICS FOR
STUDENTS OF THE PAST COUPLE OF
THE GIRLS THIS THE PENDULUM A
DAY WE HAVE THEM AUDIO. SO CAN
WE HAVE MISTER SEA MAYBE TAKE
OVER TO SEE IF HIS CONNECTION IS
ANYBODY. THAT A GOOD MORNING
FOLKS- DAVID SO HERE TO
FINANCIAL OFFICER SO TO PICK
WHERE A FAKE LEFT I DON'T OPEN
I'M COMING THROUGH OKAY. I SEEM
TO BE- THE ECO IS DOING VERY
WELL- WE BENEFITTED FROM THE OF
. IN ADDITION TO THE OF OUR
ACTED PRO. WE ARE EMBARKED UPON
THE OF REBEL MEANT- IN ACADEMIC
VILLAGE THAT WILL SUPPORT-
STUDENTS FROM MULTIPLE
INSTITUTIONS- CURRENTLY OUR
PRIMARY PARTNERS UCSF WE HAVE UC
DAVIS STUDENTS ON CAMPUS AS
WELL. TO ADDRESS ONE OF THE-
BIGGEST CHALLENGE FACING HIGHER
. UP QUICKLY URBAN. WE ARE
CURRENTLY BEING- CONSTRUCTING A
SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE UNIT
TO THE STUDENT HOUSING FACILITY-
AT. ON OUR CAMPUS IT IS UNDER
CONSTRUCTION FINANCED WITH TAX
EXEMPT THAT PROJECT REVENUES. AT
WE WILL BE OPENING UP IN THE
SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
THIS VISIBILITY WILL HOUSE
STUDENTS FROM HASTINGS
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO YOUR FIRST CALIFORNIA
DAVIS AND OTHER ACADEMIC
PARTNERS- AND THIS PART OF OUR
STRATEGIC VISION TO CREATE THE
SHARED PLATFORM- LOCATION IN SAN
FRANCISCO THAT WOULD GO ALLOW
FOR THREE JEEZ BETWEEN VARIOUS
PROGRAMS EFFICIENCIES. AS OUR
ACADEMIC VILLAGE PARTNERS WILL
ALSO HAVE FULL ACCESS TO THE
CAMPUS. YOUR LIBRARY FOR SERVICE
PARKING UP AND LIKE. SO WE'RE
WORM AND BARK I'M A OF A BOLD
VISION TO THAT PROBABLY HAS NO
PARALLEL IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
WELL UNDER WAY AND WE TRULY
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT. AT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE PROVIDED. OKAY
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A QUESTION
FROM MR LEE. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
WAS CHAIR I AM VERY APPROACH
APPRECIATE ALL THAT HE SINGS IS
DOING IS CONDUCTING BUT I WOULD
DEFINITELY WANTED TO TALK ASKED
ABOUT THE NAME CHANGE AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT YOU ALL
RECOGNIZE THERE IS A NECESSARY
APPROPRIATENESS AND CHANGING THE
NAME. I JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT FOR
THE COMMITTEE SAKE THAT HASTINGS
. SERRANO'S CLINTON HASTINGS HAS
A HISTORY AND KNOWN NOW
ESPECIALLY FOR MODERN ACADEMIA.
OF HAVING A BRUTAL REPRESSION
AND ALMOST GENOCIDE OF THE YOU
KEEP PEOPLE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO IT IS OF COURSE
VERY PROPER WE'RE NO LONGER
USING THE NAME- AND- IT'S
NOTABLE TO THAT THE- AMOUNT OF
CRUELTY WAS. EVEN FOR THE
EIGHTEEN SIXTY STANDARDS KNOWN
TO BE EXTREMELY CRUEL WHERE THEY
WOULD. GO AFTER THE FEW PEOPLE
TO ALMOST NEAR EXTERMINATION.
AND SO MY QUESTION I JUST WANT
TO ASK MORE THAN I KNOW YOUR
ENGAGED RIGHT NOW IN. THE NAME
CHANGE PROCESS RIGHT NOW. AND
I'M PLEASED TO HEAR ABOUT THAT
BUT HOW ARE YOU IF HOW YOU
INVOLVING THE AFFECTED TRIBES IN
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
YES WE CHANGE THE NAME BUT ALSO
HAVE THAT INPUT. FROM THE
AFFECTED TRIBAL TRIBAL NATIONS
AND THEN ALSO MAKING SURE
THERE'S A RESTORATIVE ASPECT IT
RIGHT PEACE NOT JUST THAT WE
HAVE A NAME CHANGE WE FORGET
THAT IT HAD NEVER HAPPENED BUT
WE WANT TO KNOWLEDGE THE HARM
THAT HAS BEEN DONE HISTORICALLY
BY. THE NAMESAKE OF THE PERSON
AND OF COURSE HAVING THE NAME
FOR SO LONG. I JUST WANT TO ASK
THEN HOW ARE YOU INVOLVING. THE
AFFECTED TRIBES IN THIS IS A
MAKING PROCESS AND HOW WE VIEW
WORK AND RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PRACTICES WELL. SEVEN BILLION
TRIED THAT AGAIN HERE UPON. THAT
KIND OF IF YOU SPEAK MORE LOUDLY
L. AND HELP I THINK IT'S YOUR
MICROPHONE THAT'S NOT AS GOOD
OKAY- IF YOU CAN HEAR ME BUT
STOP ME IF YOU CANNOT. SO WE
BEGAN THIS PROCESS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN- AND WE REACHED OUT TO
ME- AFFECTED TRIBES ARE BOTH THE
RAND VALLEY INDIAN TRIBES AND
TRIBAL COUNCIL AS WELL AS THE-
YOU CAN COMMUNITY- WHAT
SPECIFICALLY MORE GENERALLY US
OVER THE LAST. FOUR YEARS WE
HAVE BEEN- PLAN TO DEPART-
WORKING THEM I TO DEFINE
RESTORED OF. THAT I'LL GETTING
SPACE AND I'M MINIMUM IS FIFTEEN
BY. ARE TO COME. IBM TELL THEIR
STORE IN- FROM THEIR OWN- WE
HEAR AND WHO CENTER- IN THE BILL
VERY AND- WITH THAT BECAUSE
REACHED OUT TO OUR- THE WRONG
SOLANO- ON- AND CHECK PLAN. OF
THE UNIVERSITY BASED THINGS SIR
- EVERY. MORE RECENT- SINCE
EFFORT THE LARGEST HAS FORWARD I
ONE OF MANY CONSIDER WITH BOTH
TO HAVE A AND THE COMMUNITY. I'M
FROM MATTER. OF THE CAN- A GREAT
ON THE FOR. HOWEVER NEVER OF YOU
CAN JUST SEND THEM- THAT- YOU
CAN VISIT MAP TO REMOVE THE
HASTINGS AND- ARE THEY BELIEVE
THAT AS PART OF THE- JUSTICE AT.
AND WE GOT TO BE RESPECT. A
BIGGER MOVE AND THEN THERE ARE
THE P. I JUST. ARE TO. POINT OF
VIEW AND- THAT NAME SHOULD
REMOVE- AND THE HAVE THEIR OF
WHAT NAME BE A PRO. I QUIT ON
THE SCHOOL- THE FACT- THE BILL
YOU'RE GOING I WAS INCOME. ALSO
WITH UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT AND
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO- TO THE
COURSE OF THE LEGISLATURE PUT
AYE GEOGRAPHIC DESIGNATION. OUR
SCHOOLS THAT WOULD BE THE
ARRESTED CALIFORNIA HARPER SAN
FRANCISCO I'M NOT MAD MARROW IS
THAT THE CURRENT BOARD'S
OPPOSITION ABOUT HOW WE GO
FORWARD AND THAT WE'VE GOTTEN.
OFF A VERY OPEN AND TRANSPARENT
WITH ART WITH ALL OF THE
AFFECTED PROBLEM- IN ROUND ABOUT
WAY- MADELINE CHRISTMAS RATE BUT
BUT REALLY OVER THE LAST FOUR
YOU HAVE HAVING TO. HEARING SO.
IT'S REALLY NOT WORKING THAT
COMMUNICATION HERE BUT- YEAH
THAT IS AN ISSUE ON THAT THAT
NOT JUST THE NAMING BUT THE BIG
PICTURE OF- OF RECTIFYING THE
ISSUE AND HAVING SOME AS MR LEE
SAID- RESTORATIVE PRACTICES
GOING FORWARD SO. WE WILL KEEP
THIS CONVERSATION GOING AND-
THANK YOU FOR THE PARTICIPATION
ON HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN I WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT I'M GOING TO ASK
MR LEE TO TAKE OVER THIS PART OF
THE AGENDA. ELEVEN YEAH.
THAT'S WHAT I NEED TO SAY YEAH
YOU MAY WANT TO SEE IF THERE MAY
BE SOME PEOPLE HERE TOO OKAY AND
FOR TWENTY TO DO THE DISCLAIMER
FIRST. AND THEN I'LL DO FIRST
THING. I WOULD SAY READ IN THE
NOW. GO TO THE- IN PERSON AND
THEN GOT A PHONE. RIGHT WILL NOW
BE EXCEPT PUBLIC. I'M JUST GOING
TO READ THE CALL IN NUMBER NOW
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE PHONE. SO THE
PUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE SEVEN
FOUR SEVEN. AS A WILL BE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELEPHONE AS WELL. BUT WE'LL
START WITH HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
FROM INSIDE THE ROOMS IF YOU
WANT TO LINE UP TO THE
MICROPHONE RIGHT NOW IF YOU'RE
HERE TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT-
THAT WOULD BE GREAT. SO WILL BE
STARTING WITH ONE MEDICAL TO
COMMENT SO YOU MAY BEGIN. I
THANK YOU MY NAME IS AS A DAYS A
ROBBIE I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
UC BERKELEY UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
PROGRAM. AND I'M HERE TO JOIN
THE UC SYSTEM IN ASKING YOU TO
INCLUDE A FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
ONGOING ALLOCATION FOR THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS PROGRAM. TO
EXPAND AND SUSTAIN ITS PROGRAMS
UC WIDE WE HAVE A 100%
GRADUATION RATE OF 90%
ACCEPTANCE RATE WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS THAT
WE SUPPORT WITH THE UC
APPLICATION. WHERE EVERY YOU SEE
NOW WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THE
CAL STATES. AND YOU'VE ALREADY
MADE THESE ALLOCATIONS TO
FORMERLY INCARCERATED STUDENT
PROGRAMS AT THE CAL STATES AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR ASKING
YOU TO CLOSE THE GAP. THIS YEAR
BY ALSO FUNDING UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS EIGHT IN MORRIS
I'M A GRADUATING SENIOR AT UC
DAVIS AND I I'M HERE IN TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATIONS BUDGET ASKS FOR
THIS YEAR. AND SO THE FIRST ONE
I WANT TO GO THROUGH IS THAT CAL
GRANT THE CAL GRANT IS ONE OF
THE BEST. TOOLS OUR STATE HAS TO
HELP LOW INCOME STUDENTS AFFORD
A COLLEGE DEGREE. BUT WITH THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS NOT MEETING
THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS. I'M A CAL
GRANT RECIPIENT MYSELF AND A
TRANSFER STUDENT AND WITHOUT THE
CAL GRANT I WOULD HAVE FACED AT
SERIOUS HOUSING INSECURITY OR
STUDENT LOANS. I'M GOING TO UC
DAVIS. AND IF WE ARE GOING TO
REALIZE OUR GOAL OF DEBT FREE
COLLEGE EDUCATION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WE MUST ABOUT
INVEST IN THE CAL GRANT. AND I
ALSO WANT TO BRING SUPPORT- AT-
JUST. BRING UP THIS SAY PAT
PROGRAM ONCE AGAIN REALLY QUICK
I KNOW THAT THIS WAS TOUCHED ON
EARLIER BUT THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
A GREAT SUCCESS RATE. WITH THAT
76% OF HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND
C. PAP PROGRAMS- ENROLLING IN
COLLEGE. SO WE WANT TO SEE A
TWENTY TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OF ON GOING FUNDING FOR
SAY PAT. AND THE FUTURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS CELINA EIGHTEEN AND I'M
A SECOND YEAR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS I'M ALSO
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION BUDGET ASKS
FOR THIS YEAR SO I WANTED TO GO
OVER SOME INITIAL EQUITY SO EASY
ACCESS TO FREE MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS ON UC CAMPUSES IS AN
ISSUE OF HUMAN RIGHTS GENDER
EQUITY AND EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO
EDUCATION I'M DESPITE THERE
BEING PROGRESS BEING MADE IN
MENSTRUAL EQUITY ON OUR CAMPUSES
DUE TO ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY
SEVEN IN THE LAST YEAR WE DO
NEED MORE FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO
INSTALL DISPENSERS IN MORE THAN
JUST ONE BATHROOM. ON OUR
CAMPUSES THIS YEAR YOU CSA'S
ASKING FOR TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION IN ONGOING FUNDING TO
ALLOW FOR INSTALLMENT OF THE
SPENCERS OF FREE MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS IN 50% OF ALL DOCTORS
ACROSS THE UC CAMPUSES I ALSO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT ONCE AGAIN THE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT PROGRAMS IS
THERE ARE OVER FOUR THOUSAND
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS IN THE UC
SYSTEM AND UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE UC ARE
AT RISK OF ENDING DUE TO A LACK
OF FUNDING WITHIN TWO YEARS
THERE WILL BE NO MORE UC OR CSU
STUDENTS WITH DACA STATUS.
MEANING THEY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
GET WORK CLEARANCE OR SIGN ON
FOR THEIR OWN HOUSING FUNDING
FOR THESE PROGRAMS IS URGENT TO
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE THE
MENTORSHIP IMPLEMENT MATERIAL
SUPPORT TO FELLOWSHIPS AND
FINANCIAL AID TO UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS SO DESPERATELY NEED TO
GET THROUGH COLLEGE THIS YEAR
UCSF ASKING FOR FIFTEEN MILLION
IN ONGOING FUNDING SO FIVE
MILLION FOR THE UC'S AND TEN
MILLION FOR CSU'S FRONT
DOCUMENTED STUDENT PROGRAMS TO
ALLOW THESE PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE
PROVIDE TOOK CAN CONTINUE
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS. AND
ENSURE THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO COMPLETE UC OR CSU DEGREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME'S
MICHAEL FELDBERG AND I AM A
THIRD YEAR UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DAVIS. AND I ALSO JUST WANT TO
COMMENT ON SOME OF THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATIONS BUDGET
ASKS- JUST TO KIND OF REITERATE
AGAIN I KNOW WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER BUT THE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS PROGRAMS. ARE
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL AND
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS AT THE CAMPUS
IS THAT CURRENTLY DO HAVE THEM-
THEY SEE LIKE IN TERMS OF
RECIDIVISM- BASICALLY A 100%
SUCCESS RATE- IN TERMS OF THE
PARTICIPANTS THEY NEVER END UP
BACK IN THE SYSTEM SO. WE ARE
ASKING FOR A FOUR MILLION FOUR
FOUR MILLION AN ON GOING FUNDING
TO HELP KIND OF STANDARDIZE AND
BUILD UP THESE PROGRAMS ACROSS
ALL UC CAMPUSES- AND THEN ALSO
JUST TO REITERATE THE FOSTER
YOUTH PROGRAMS- DO YOU SEE SOON
ASSOCIATION WAS REALLY GRATEFUL
TO SEE THE GOVERNOR'S- BUDGET-
INDEED GOVERNOR'S INCLUSION OF
SIX MILLION AND ONGOING FUNDING
IN THE BUDGET. AND WE JUST WANT
TO EXPRESS OUR SINCERE SUPPORT
FOR THIS FUNDING. IN TERMS OF
FOSTER YOUTH AND THE CHALLENGES
THEY FACE THEY FACE TOWARDS
ATTAINING AN UPPER A HIGHER
EDUCATION- SO WE JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THE IMPORTANCE OF AND
OUR SUPPORT FOR THESE PROGRAMS-
WITH THAT SAID WE ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR WORK AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING OUR
BUDGET ASKED INCLUDING THE MAY
REVISE. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH. BRIGITTE SEE SO MANY OF MY
FELLOW AGGIES HERE. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS JENNIFER GOMEZ I'M
WITH UC SAN DIEGO AND I'M HERE
ASKING FOR THE FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS AS A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED ALUMNI
FROM UC SAN DIEGO I JUST WANNA
LET YOU KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IS TO
HAVE THIS PROGRAM ON OUR
CAMPUSES. NOT ONLY DOES IT
EMPOWER US BUTIT HELPS US
PROVIDE FOR COMMUNITIES BE
BETTERPARTICIPANTS IN OUR LIVES
AND JUST BE THERE FOR FAMILIES-
WITHOUT THIS PROGRAM I WOULDN'T
BE WHERE I AM TODAY- A POLICY
FELLOW AND HERE AT THE CAPITOL
SO I JUST REALLY URGE YOU TO
CONTINUE- OR TO SUPPORT US IN
THIS ON GOING FUNDING FOR OUR
CAMPUSES THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK
YOU. HELLO GOOD MORNING.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
JOSHUA SO LEASE I AM
REPRESENTING A UC SANTA CRUZ-
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT IN A REQUEST FOR
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS. PERSONALLY
I'M FORMALLY INCARCERATE AFTER
SERVING ABOUT ELEVEN YEARS- OF
MY DOING TIME OF ELEVEN YEARS- I
GOT I WENT THROUGH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE GRADUATED FROM UC SANTA
CRUZ NOW I'M CURRENTLY PURSUING
MY MASTERS- SACRAMENTO STATE- SO
I'M HERE TO SAY THA THE PROGRAM
WORKS- AND I'M HERE TO. SUPPORT
AND REQUEST THAT YOU SUPPORT US-
WITH A FOREMAN SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. HELLO GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS DIMITRIS
LARA. I AM THE CO FOUNDER OF THE
RISING SCHOLARS MENTORSHIP
PROGRAM AT SOUTHWESTERN COLLEGE
AND SAN DIEGO. I'M HERE
SUPPORTING THE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS IN THE REQUEST TO
RECEIVE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS. IN
ONGOING FUNDING TO BETTER
SUPPORT FORMALLY INCARCERATED
STUDENTS TO BUILD STRONGER
COMMUNITY FOR ALL OF US. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND NOW WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. ARE THERE ANY. FOLKS
QUEUED UP IN THE PHONE LINES. WE
HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE ACCUSE. I'M
SORRY. SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR COMMENTS ALL RIGHT
LET'S START WITH SOME COMMON.
ONE MINUTE COMMENT PLEASE. HELLO
MY NAME IS MICHAEL I'M A STUDENT
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SANTA BARBARA I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF UTSA TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THE PROVISION OF MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS AT THE UC'S- ALTHOUGH
THERE BEEN STRIDES MADE TOWARD-
MAKING THE PROVISION OF HYGIENIC
PRODUCTS MORE EQUITABLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA- THROUGH THE PASSAGE
OF EIGHTY THREE FIFTY SEVEN THIS
IS NOT ACTUALLY- EXPANDS TO THE
YOUTH FEES SO WE'RE JUST ASKING
FOR FUNDING TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS HAVE. A ALL
THE THINGS THEY NEED TO OBTAIN
AN EDUCATION AND MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE NO ACTIVE PLAYERS ON
OUR CAMPUS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WERE GONE THE NEXT CALLER.
FIFTEEN ONE FIVE. GOOD MORNING
KATRINA RENDON ON BEHALF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE CONFLICT AND TAKING
ACTION TO PRESERVE THE RIGHT TO
ACCESS TO QUALITY PUBLIC HIGHER
ED ACT THE NUMBER YOU CALIFORNIA
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
STRATEGIC MULTI YEAR FUNDING
PROPOSAL IN THE ALLOCATION OF
THREE HUNDRED SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE UC TO
GROW CALIFORNIA'S STUDENT
ENROLLMENT AND ACCESS. WE ALSO
SUPPORTED COMPANY EXPECTATIONS
ABOUT THE FIFTH OF MARCH CONTACT
RECAP IN A MOMENT I THINK THAT.
ONE VALUE SHIPPED WILL BRING IT
CLOSER TO A- PER DEGREE CAME ASK
BECAUSE I GOVERNOR. AND ARE
RECEIVING SHOWED HELLO TO GROW
NUMBER OF. STUDENTS NIGHT ACT
THE THAT HAVE YOU. A FAILURE TO
A MULTI ECONOMIC GROWTH. BUT SHE
THE CALL JUNE TWO GENERATIONS
WITH THE TYPICAL IMPACT FELT BY
THE- WHITE AND BLACK AND LOW
INCOME SHE- FORTY. IS NEEDED NOW
MORE THAN EVER ENSURE A PATH TO
RECOVERY. AND THINKING FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU. GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MOVE NEXT CALL. LINE SO. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE MY IS BERNIE
ENDING AND I'M WITH AT UC
RIVERSIDE I'M HERE TO THEIR OF
THE UC AT THE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF OUR YOU SEE
STUDENTS ALSO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT ON THE MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS AT THE STATE IN OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE GOVERNOR NEW
SOME PAST EIGHTY THREE SIXTY
SEVEN THE MANAGER EQUITY ACT
WHICH MANDATED POLICY CAMPUS IS
TO PROVIDE FREE PERIOD PRODUCTS
THE STUDENTS HOWEVER THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO FUNDING THAT WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT COLLEGE CAMPUSES
TO DO THE BEST. IN FACT EVEN
MEET THAT REQUIREMENT BY THE
SUMMER WHEN THE LAW GOES INTO
EFFECT SO PLEASE TAKE THE INTO
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. LINE. TWENTY
FOUR. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
NOT A WHOLE CRITICS NINE STUDENT
AT UC SANTA BARBARA I'M HERE
TODAY TO PART OF THE U. STUDENT
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF OUR USERS AND ALSO
AND YOUR SUPPORT ON THE
UNDERGROUND PRO AT THE UC UNDER
GONZALEZ THE RESURFACING THEY
NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL. HOWEVER
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
SCHOLAR ONLY WHICH A LOT TIME
FOR THE- ASKING FOR THE GAS
BECAUSE CONTROL FORMALLY THREE
AND AN IMPACT CREDIT THE LEVEL
AS WELL YEAH. THANK YOU. WHY
TWENTY EIGHT. HELLO GOOD MORNING
MY IS AND CALM I'M A STUDENT
THANK YOU SANTA AND I'M HERE ON
THE OF THE STUDENTS SO SHE- AND-
URGES THE POOR ON AND TO PRO
WE'RE ASKING FOR MILLION ONGOING
FOR THE UC- AND TEN MILLION FOR
THE CSU. SO I HAVE BEEN TALKING
SISTER WHO IS THE UC- IRVINE A
LOT AND I THINK HEALTHCARE
SERVICE. WORK FOR HER TO FIND
THEIR COUNTLESS TIMES MY SISTER
WOULD CALL HOME AFTER MY MOM TO
BRING FOOD BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING
TO EIGHT DAYS WITHOUT EATING. MY
SISTERS EVAN DOCUMENTS STUDENT
WAS ONCE SHE GOT WITH HER CELL
NO FRIEND OF HERS WERE
UNDOCUMENTED MADE IT TO COLLEGE.
THE ONE THAT SHE MET IN COLLEGE
WITH THEIR IDENTITY BECAUSE THE
POLITICAL CLIMATE MINISTER
REMEMBERS STUDENTS GO TO WHAT
YOU SEE I CAMPUS TO SUPPORT TO
SHOW SUPPORT BUT- AND
DEPORTATION OF UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS. BUILDING AND
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES
DIFFICULT WINNERS OF THE
PULITZER PRIZE THE WAY IT.
PROVIDEDBUT NOT MAKE ANY
DIFFERENCE BUT BECAUSE THE UC
LACKS RESOURCES WHERE DOCUMENTS
STUDENTS THERE HAVE REALLY
PUSHED ON THE SITE WHERE PEOPLE
CAN BE HUMANIZED AND WITHOUT ANY
CONSEQUENCES. BUT THAT THERE IS
AN EDUCATION THE WAY I AM
REQUESTING IT BUT EXPERIENCE WAS
RADICALLY DIFFERENT. WITH THE
SUPPORT GROUPS AFTER THE LONDON
SELDOM. AND SCHOOLS AND ENOUGH
SHE WILL. UC'S GIVE OF THE THAT
THE NOT WHEN THEY NEED NOT ONLY
LEGAL AID DEPARTMENT HEALTH
SUPPORT RECRUIT AND- PROGRAM.
MUZZIN DUCKS STUDENTS ARE NOT AS
FORTUNATE TO HAVE BEEN MOTHER
CLOSE ENOUGH TO BRING THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU THANK YOU. WHY
TWENTY. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS KIANA STUDY I MISSED USE
SANTA BARBARA HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE U. BY CHOIR I WOULD LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE HOME FOR STUDENT
ACADEMIC PREPARATION PROGRAM R.
J. ARE YOU SEE STUDENTS STEP UP
SEARCH THE BROAD OF UNDER
THIRTEEN PRACTICE ON A DIAPER
HERE I YEAR AND SAYS I'M
STRUGGLE TO REALLY IN VALUE NOT
ONLY YOU STUDENT ALSO CALL
PROPER FOR FUTURES AND THOSE IN.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TAPE OF
GENTLEMEN CONTINUOUSLY REDUCED
BY BUDGET CUTS- AND THIS IS WHY
I ADVOCATE FOR THE BUDGET ASK A
TWENTY TWO POINT FIVE MILLION ON
GOING TO FUND STATE THAT AND
IT'S PROGRAMS TO SUSTAIN IN
PREPARATION. THAT ARE AT THE
CORE OF THE UC THANK YOU FOR
YOUR. TIME THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS THE VIEW AS AN AND THE
YOUR YOUR YOU CAN ON YOUR CARD
YOU CAN ME THIRTY EIGHT CENTER
DUE TO EIGHT THREE SIX SEVEN
PROVIDING POINT FIVE NO DOLLARS
THE FUNDING MUNSTER CENTERS AT
THE UC AND IF UPCOMING BUT THAT
AND TWENTY TWO ONE GOVERNOR NEED
POTTS AB THREE SEVEN WHICH
MANDATED CALL CAMPUS TO PROVIDE
FREE COUPON. HOWEVER THE
CURRENTLY NO FUNDING THAT WOULD
MAKE SURE THE YOU CAN. MEET THE
REQUIRED WHEN THE LAW GOES INTO
EFFECT THIS SUMMER. THIS OP
INSTEAD THE CALIFORNIA PROVIDE
EQUAL ACCESS. TO AND ENABLE GOLF
. TO REACH THEIR GOAL TO. YEAH
THANK YOU. LIED THIRTEEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JORDAN SOSA A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IN CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION HE WHAT HE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR SIX MILLION DOLLARS
ARE GOING GENERAL FUND BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR YOU SEE IF THE PORT
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
SUPPORT PROGRAMS WE ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO STATE THAT IT IS VITAL
THAT THE COMMITTEE ADOPTS
LANGUAGE THAT GUARANTEES THE
FUNDS GO EXCLUSIVELY TO THE
PROGRAMS WE BELIEVE THAT
LANGUAGE WHAT THE POOR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS. MORE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE FOSTER
CARE COMMUNITY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE. FORTY HELLO- DEBBIE
RUSHER WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR USE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FOSTER YOUTH
PROGRAMS I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE ADOPT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
ENSURES THAT INSTITUTIONS USE
THE FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE VERY
SUCCESSFUL TARGETED PROGRAMS
ALREADY IN PLACE ON CAMPUS.
THANK YOU. FORTY THREE. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ALLISON
HAMBLY AND I'M CURRENTLY A
JUNIOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS I AM CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING IN MY UNIVERSITY
PROGRAM AFTER YEARS AND BEFORE
AN ALLOCATION OF SIX MILLION FOR
THE PROGRAM ALSO IT IS VITAL
THAT THE COMMITTEE ADOPTED
LANGUAGE LIKE GUARANTEES THAT
FUNDS GO WITH THE BIG DEBATE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FORTY EIGHT. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHELLE ANDREWS- I'M THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
ASSOCIATED STUDENTS OF UC DAVIS-
CALLING TO FIRST BANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR CENTERING
STUDENT VOICES THE NEEDS- AND
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR ALL
OF THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION
BUDGET- I ALSO WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE THAT BROUGH BY FELLOW
STUDENTS FOR CALLING IN AND
SHOWING UP IN PERSON- IT'S
FINALS WEEK AND WE'RE ALL TAKING
TIME OUT OF OUR FINAL. WEEK TO
COMMUNICATE WITH YOU HOW MUCH WE
NEED TO BE THOUGHT TO ASK- SO WE
REALLY HOPE THAT- YOU WILL WORK
TO GET THE EXACT INTO THE MAY
REVISE ON BEHALF OF US- ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. FORTY NINE.
GOOD MORNING THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND BY THE END OF RAIN
AS BALLOT I'M A CURRENT STUDENT
AT UC BERKELEY AND LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE OFFENSE GET A
STUDENT BACK HOUSE I'D LIKE TO
VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR ADOPTING
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FINANCIAL ACTIVITY ACROSS THE
STATE AT THE STUDENTS I CANNOT
EMPHASIZE ENOUGH HOW MUCH MENTAL
HEALTH AS A BASIC HUMAN NEED THE
OFTEN GOES ON THAT ON OUR
CAMPUSES THIS IS A CHANCE THE UC
ABOUT A NATIONAL EXAMPLE AT THE
UNIVERSITY BUT SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS. AND THAT'S MY URGE YOU
TO PROVIDE THE FUNDS THANK YOU.
THANKS SO MUCH. FOR FIVE. DID I
UC BERKELEY I PARTICIPATE MY
UNIVERSITIES FOR FOSTER YOUTH- I
AM A FORMER BOSS YOUTH I DON'T
HAVE PARENTS OR IF FINE SUPPORT
ME I'M NOT THAT GREAT TO HIRE.
AND STUDENT ALIKE WE ARE HIGH
AND THESE STRICT PROGRAM AT
THEIR PERSONAL AND YOU INSTITUTE
INSTITUTION IN ORDER TO MAKE IT
TO GRADUATION THAT'S WHY I'M
ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT.
ALLOCATION THANK THE- DOLLARS
FOR THE PRO I ALSO WANTED THE-
BUT IT IS ABSOLUTELY. THAT THEY
CAN ADOPT LANGUAGE. THAT
GUARANTEE THAT THESE ARE
COLLECTION. TO DESCRIBE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MONEX CAR. FIFTY
HELLO MY NAME IS THEIR RATE
OFTEN AND THE DIRECTOR OF
SERVICES FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS
AT UC SANTA CRUZ I SUPPORT
ALLOCATION OF SIX MILLION FOR
FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAM FOUR
MILLION FOR UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
PROGRAM AT THE UC'S THIS
INVESTMENT WILL IMPACT UC'S
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
FORMALLY INCARCERATED AT THE
COMPACTED STUDENTS AN
INDEPENDENT AGENT IN THE
FOLLOWING WAYS WILL BE ABLE TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES AND HELP
HOUSING AND FINANCIAL SECURITY
DURING AND AFTER COLLEGE
VALIDATE STUDENTS EXPERIENCES
FOR CHEATING OR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS AND. INCREASE GRADUATION
RATES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIFTY THREE. HI MY NAME IS A
MASTER AND I'M THE ATP EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS VICE PRESIDENT FROM UC
BERKELEY I'M HERE TODAY TO
REITERATE POLITICIANS OPT FOR
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING FROM CENTRAL EQUITY I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY TIMES
I'VE HAD TO STAY IN MALE
DOMINATED SPACES IN DECEMBER
BUDGET COMMITTEES AND GOVERNMENT
AREAS WHERE I'VE BEEN TOLD MY
TRACK WE NEED NOT A BASIC NEED
AS A WOMAN AND ALSO DURING
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH I REALLY
URGE YOU AND THANK YOU TO
CONSIDER HOW SEXUAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS. HAVE BEEN
CONTINUOUSLY USED TO UNDERMINE
AND ACROSS WOMEN THROUGHOUT
HISTORY IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE MY
FACULTY IS A BASIC NEEDS THAT WE
REALIZED BY PERIOD POVERTY IS AN
ONGOING ISSUE AT ALL OF OUR
CAMPUSES AND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO SUPPORT HALF OF OUR STUDENT
POPULATION WHO OF COURSE OF
THEIR LIVES HOW TO DEAL WITH AND
EXPERIENCE BUT MINISTRATION. DOT
THEIR BODIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THIRTY GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN RESPONDENT THE ON
BEHALF OF THE U. A. W. TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE AND YOUR W.
FIFTY EIGHT TEN WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
WHICH WILL MAKE HISTORIC
INVESTMENT IN YOUTH WORKERS WE
ARE GRATEFUL TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR TAKING QUICK
ACTION YESTERDAY DURING THE OPEN
ENROLLMENT ISSUE THE BERKELEY IN
PARTICULAR WE SUPPORT THE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION FOR CLIMATE
RESILIENCY FUNDING FOR CLIMATE
RESEARCH AND INNOVATION HUBS
WILL DIRECTLY BENEFIT OUR
MEMBERS MANY OF WHOM ARE
CONDUCTING CUTTING EDGE RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPING NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
TO MITIGATE THE WORST EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE FOR OUR STATE AND
FOR ALL FOR THE WORLD HOWEVER IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WE MUST ALSO
ADDRESS THE COST OF LIVING
CRISIS AFFECTING THE WORKERS WHO
WERE CONDUCTING THATVITAL
RESEARCH RECENT DATA SHOWS THAT
90% OF TWENTY FIFTY FIVE WORKERS
AND WORKERS 70% OF FIFTY EIGHT
TEN REPRESENTED WORKERS ARE RENT
BURDENED LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM WITHIN CRISIS. FOR ALL
STUDENTS AND WORKERS. I DIDN'T
SEE MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FIFTY FOUR. HELLO AND GOOD
MORNING TO YOU ARE MY NAME IS
DIANA PRETTY HOME AND I'M A
STUDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY I'M A FIRST
YEAR STUDENT AND I PARTICIPATE
IN BERKELEY HOPE SCHOLARS A
PROGRAM WHICH HAS HELPED ME AND
OTHER FOSTER YOUTH EXTENSIVELY
I'M SUPPORTING AN ALLOCATION AND
ALLOCATION OF SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE STATE BUDGET
SUPPORT PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS
WITH DOCTORS CARE EXPERIENCE
INCLUDING MYSELF ACROSS THE UC
SYSTEM EVERYBODY THAT THE
COMMUNITY ADOPTED LANGUAGE AND
SECURITY THAT THE FUNDING GO
THE OTHER PARTY YOU'D BETTER IN
SIMILAR CIRCUMSTANCES ASK MYSELF
WITH NO FAMILY OR SUPPORT
PROGRAMS LIKE THESE MAKE IT
POSSIBLE. FOR US TO HAVE ACCESS
TO HIGH EDUCATION. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU SOME. CONTACTS CALL.
FORTY SIX. HELLO GOOD MORNING
ALL MY NAME ASK ABOUT THEIR OWN
INTERNET YEAR STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY AND AUTHOR UNITED
STATES ARMY VETERAN- BURKE
WITHHOLD SCHOLARS AND
UNDERGROUND CALLER I HAD REALLY
DEPEND ON SCHOOL FUNDED PROGRAMS
FOR EDUCATION I'VE BEEN MANY I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE ALBUM
FEATURES NEARLY FOR THE PART B.
PROGRAM IMPORTANT. FOR THE
UNDERGROUND COLLEGE PROGRAM DID
BY ALL THAT THE COMEDIA DEL
LANGUAGE THAT HE DONE GOING TO
BE TO BE SPENT OR EDUCATIONAL
PROGRESS IT IS THE TOPIC THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
KNECHTEL LINE FIFTY AT. WHICH
MORNING MEMBERS- OF MINE ARE THE
EMINEM THAT YOU DAVIS PROVIDES
GOVERNMENT IN FRANCE DEFENSE FOR
THE UC TO HERE- YOU'RE- FOR
TWENTY TWO FIVE NINE DOLLARS ON
GOING FOR PEPPER. SOME OF THESE
AFTER BENEFIT TRANSFERS TO MAKE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THE
PROGRAM INCLUDE TO STOP TRÊN
PATH NEEDS TO AND DAY BUT
THOUGHT WERE IS USED OVER TO
TIMES NNUALLY BY STUDENTS AND
AB DE PERCENT OF THE AFFECTED IN
THE PER TRANSFERRED TO YOU SEE.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WHICH IS TO
INCREASE OUT IN THE CALL DO YOU
AND ONGOING AND IN THE PROGRAMS
NEEDED TO PROVIDE A CLEAR NEED
FOR TO MANY CURRENT AND BE
TRAFFIC THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. EXCEPT FIT FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS NOT ANSWER
WHICH GOVERNOR RELATIONS THE UC
ASSOCIATION I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
BERMAN UCSC SOME FOR THE MANY
FACETS IS BUT I TODAY INCLUDING
MEASURE EQUITY UNDER STILL
PROGRAMS- PROGRAMS FOR YOU STATE
THAT PROGRAM. AND UNDERGONE
SELLERS AND ALL THESE PROGRAMS
ARE FOR INSURING ACCESS EQUITY
AND- AND SUCCESS FOR STUDENTS OF
DIFFERENT MEANS THAT THE UC WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING ALL OF
THIS AND THIS YEAR'S BUDGET AND
WE HAVE THE SIZE OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE ESSENTIAL PART OF
I'M FULLY. REALIZING THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE. SIXTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE MONEY WITH IT
THE STATURE AND I AM HERE FOR
YOU YES THE- I'M A MEMBER OF THE
SCHOLARS A PROGRAM WHAT THE
PROGRAM TO HELP TALK TO YOU WELL
. FORMER BOXER YOU- YOU KNOW
THEY- OKAY. WHEN YOU- GO TO
COLLEGE A STATE COLLEGE HERE
AND- I THINK FOR BASICALLY
DOLLARS AND- THIS IS A BLANK
THAT THE FUNDS. TO THE PARK
ITSELF THANK YOU. EXCEPT. SIXTY
FIVE. IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR IN
MY AND I'M A STUDENT AT UC
IRVINE I'M OFF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
ACCEPTED STUDENTS OF UC IRVINE
AND I'M CALLING OF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR U. P. AND DOCUMENTED
YOU DON'T PROGRAM- I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE-
DISCREPANCIES OR HE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS IT'S ONLY ONE IN TEN ON
DOCUMENTS HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
ARE PORTED AND I'LL- TO FINISH
COLLEGE AND RECEIVE A BACHELOR
DEGREE OR THE VAST MAJORITY OF
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ARE FIRST
GENERATION- AND- OF STUDENTS OF
LOWER INCOME BACKGROUND- AND
THIS IT ALSO THE DAILY FACT.
THERE IMPROVE THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH IS A RECENT STUDY SHOWED
THAT UNDOCUMENTED UNDERGRADUATES
REPORTED SIGNIFICANTLY ELEVATED
LEVELS OF ANXIETY COMPARED TO
THEIR PEERS TWENTY EIGHT POINT
5% OF MALES AND THIRTY SIX POINT
7% FEMALE PARTICIPANTS- INVITED
CORPORATE BUT OKAY- NOT- NOTING
CAN'T DECIDE INSTRUCTABLE. THANK
YOU. EXCEPT SIXTIETH. HI MY NAME
IS HUNTER- CAN BE ON A THIRTY AT
UCI ALSO MAJOR- I WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO- VOICE MY- MY SUPPORT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED BE ENOUGH TO BE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT PROGRAM
AND- BUT BUDGET ALLOCATION- I'D
LIKE TO SAY THAT. MENTIONED THAT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS
THE HIGHEST FINANCIAL FROM BACK
IN THE ONE OUT OF EVERY TWO
COLLEGE STUDENTS REPORTED
MISSING HILLS PLEASE GAPS RESULT
IN SEVERE RATES OF HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS AMONG UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS- THANK YOU- HELLO. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING.
AND SIX SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
YVONNE FAN AND I AM A FIRST YEAR
PUBLIC HEALTH STUDENT FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IRVINE.
I WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT PROGRAMS IN
BUDGET ALLOCATION. I WANT TO
REITERATE THAT A RECENT STUDY
SHOWED THAT UNDOCUMENTED
UNDERGRADUATES REPORTED
SIGNIFICANTLY ELEVATED LEVELS OF
ANXIETY COMPARED TO THEIR PEERS.
AND TWENTY EIGHT POINT 5% OF
MALE AND THIRTY SIX POINT 7% A
FEMALE PARTICIPATING ANXIETY
SCORES ARE ABOUT THE CLINICAL
CUT OFF LEVEL I WHICH MEANS THEY
HAVE SIGNIFICANT ANXIETY AND
STRESS LEVELS I'M COMPARED YOUR
4% AND 9% OF THE NORM
POPULATION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH. METRIC
LINE. SIXTY THREE. HELLO MY NAME
IS AND YOUR LAST WEEK I'M A
STUDENT AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY ARE YOU
CALLING IN REGARDING KEY TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR HOUSE
FOR MENSTRUAL EQUITY UNTIL IT IS
HIGHLY IMPORTANT THAT THIS
UNIQUE B. MATT SAID REALLY IS A
HUMAN RIGHT AT THIS POINT IN
AGE- I'M REALLY HOPEFUL AND I
GIVE ALL MY THANKS AND
APPRECIATION OF THOSE UP SUPPORT
SINCE YOU'RE STARTING A REALLY
EXCELLENT PRECEDENT FOR THE
FUTURE I DON'T KNOW WHAT UC
SYSTEM. BUT THE SMALL BUT
CALIFORNIA'S ON THIS COUNTRY
CONSENT FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND HOPE YOU HAVE A GOOD DAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. YEAH NINE
SEVEN IS GOING. HELLO MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA COLLIER AND I'M A
SOCIAL POLICY AND PUBLIC SERVICE
STUDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE AND I ALSO
WANTED TO STATE MY SUPPORT FOR
THE BUDGET BRANDED UNDOCUMENTED.
STUDENTS ONLY ONE IN AND
UNDOCUMENTED CALGARY HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE R. FORTY OPPORTUNITY TO
FINISH COLLEGE AND RECEIVED A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE ALTHOUGH THE
VAST MAJORITY OF UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS ARE FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS. OF COLOR AND LOW
INCOME BACKGROUND SO I JUST
WANTED TO REITERATE MY SUPPORT
FOR THE BUDGET. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. CURRENTLY NO FURTHER
COMMENT. RIGHT SEEING AS THERE'S
NO MORE PUBLIC CALLING THE
PHONES AND- IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM THIS BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE IS
HEREBY ADJOURNED.